GOOD
MORNING WELCOME TO TODAY'S
SUNSET OVERSIGHT HEARING. WHICH
IS BEING HELD JOINTLY BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS AND THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. DUE TO THIS
CURRENT STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THING HERE IN THE CHAMBERS AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE VIRTUALLY TODAY VIA
WEBEX CONFERENCING TECHNOLOGY.
AS WELL WITNESSES ALSO LISTED
ON THE AGENDA FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO TESTIFY
REGARDING ANY OF THE ENTITIES
BEING REVIEW TODAY WE'LL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING. IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
THE ENTITY FOR WHICH YOU WISH
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE ASK
THAT WHEN YOU CALL IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
AT THIS ALSO DOES INCLUDE
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
WITNESSES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE NOTE THAT
YOU'LL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MUTING AND UNLEASHING
YOURSELVES TODAY. TODAY WILL BE
HEARING TO ENTITIES SUBJECT TO
THE SUNSET REVIEW THE FIRST ONE
IS THE BOARD OF VOCATIONAL
NURSING AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS. AND THE SECOND ONE
TODAY IS THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT EACH OF THESE ENTITIES
TODAY MAY NOT HAVE OFFICIAL
POSITIONS ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED. IN THAT CASE WE ASK
THAT THE STAFF PROVIDE AN
INFORMAL LEVEL ANSWERS TO THAT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY BE
INFORMED. LIKE TO THINK AGAIN
MY COLLEAGUES SHARE ROTH FOR
HIS PARTNERSHIP THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS AS WELL AS SENATE STAFF.
AS TO MAKING SURE THAT HAS A
SUCCESSFUL CENTS OF REVIEW. OF
WITH THAT CELL TURNOVER CENTER
ROTH FOR ANY INITIAL COMMENTS
AND ANY- FOLLOWED BY ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR ROB.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
EFFORT JOINTLY IT'S- CERTAINLY-
A PLEASURE- THAT WE CAN DO SO
IN THIS LEGISLATURE AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER ROTH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. C. NUMBER GET A
STRAIGHT RIGHT INTO IT THEN.
WILL BE NOW START WITH THE
SUNSET REVIEW FOR THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. WE
ASKED THAT THE BOARD LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS IN THEIR OPENING
REMARKS TO NO MORE THAN THREE
MINUTES. WITHIN TAKE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AND THEN OPEN IT UP TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. FOR THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
JOINING US TODAY ARE PRIMARY AS
PRIMARILY PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE
ELAINE YAMAGUCHI EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. AND DR CAROL MOUNTAIN
BOARD PRESIDENT. WITH THAT SAID
LET'S TURN IT OVER. TO YOU
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO PRESENT THE WORK
AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE BBMP
T. OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC SITUATION I HAVE TO
SAY THAT THIS PAST YEAR HAS
BEEN LIKE NO OTHER. ANYONE WHO
WORKS IN HEALTH CARE OR
EDUCATION HAS HAD TO RE EXAMINE
THE WAY IN WHICH WE WORK AND
ARE EXPECTED OUTCOMES. ALTHOUGH
THE PAST YEAR BROUGHT
CHALLENGES NO ONE EXPECTED THE
BORDERS CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
THREE IMPORTANT AREAS. CONSUMER
PROTECTION. AGAINST
CONSTITUENTS SUPPORT AND
COLLABORATION. THESE THREE
CORNERSTONES PROVIDE THE BASIS
FOR THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED THUS FAR AND THE
CONTINUING EFFORTS FROM THE B.
B. AND P. T. I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO WALK
THROUGH EACH OF THESE AREAS TO
DEMONSTRATE WHAT THE BOARD IS
ALREADY ACCOMPLISHED. WHAT IT
IS CURRENTLY WORKING ON AND HOW
DID SPEAKS WITH ITS LONG TERM
GOALS. THE FIRST CATEGORY
CONSUMER PROTECTION HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED BY THE REBUILDING
OF THE ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT. ESTABLISHING AN
INTO AND IN SCREENING UNIT. AND
FILLING THE VACANCIES IN THIS
DIVISION. MOST RECENTLY THE
BOARD AGREED TO SEND SIXTY
BACKLOG CASES TO THE AG'S
OFFICE. THAT PUBLIC PROTECTION
AND CONSUMER NEED WERE OF
HIGHEST PRIORITY IS TO ENSURE
THAT THE CASES WILL BE HEARD IN
A TIMELY MANNER AND THOSE
NEEDING REVIEW FROM THE FULL
BOARD WILL STILL BE PROCESSED.
THE BOARD HAS IDENTIFIED THE
ASPECTS OF CONSTITUENTS SUPPORT
THEY CAN ASSIST IN CREATING
BETTER RELATIONSHIPS WITH ITS
MEMBERS AND STAKEHOLDERS. UNDER
THE BOARD IS WORKING ON HIS TO
CONSIDER CHANGING THE TITLE OF
THE PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN. NO
ONE IS SURE WHAT THIS MEANS
ANYMORE AS A TERM ORIGINATED
WHEN THE STATE RUN PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS WERE MUCH MORE
PROLIFIC IT IS A TITLE THAT HAS
LONG BEEN CONSIDERED OUTDATED.
BBMP T. HAS ALSO INCREASED ITS
CONSUMER RESPONSIVENESS BY THE
FOLLOWING ACTIONS. THE DECREASE
OF PROCESSING TIME FOR KIDS
EVEN THOUGH THERE HAS BEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF THE
IN APPLICATIONS. ASSISTING TIME
WENT FROM APPROXIMATELY FIVE
POINT FIVE WEEKS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT TWO FIVE WEEKS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. THE DECREASE IN THE
WAIT TIME FOR INCOMING CALLS IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WENT
FROM THIRTY SIX MINUTES TO
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MINUTES IN
TWENTY TWENTY. SOME OF THIS HAS
BEEN ACCOMPLISHED AS THE OPEN
POSITIONS AT THE BBMP G. HAVE
BEEN BILL MAKING THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC
ON CONSTITUENTS FUNCTION MORE
SMOOTHLY. THE THIRD CORNERSTONE
IS COLLABORATION. THIS
COLLABORATION INCLUDES INTERNAL
WORK BETWEEN THE BOARD AND THE
BBMP TEAM WITH ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS AND WITH OUR
INDUSTRY PARTNERS. THE CURRENT
WORK AT THE RESTAURANT THERAPY
BOARD TO CREATE REGULATIONS
REGARDING THE MANAGEMENT OF
VENTILATED PATIENTS REACHES
ACROSS ALL THREE OF THESE FROM
THE BBMP T. ITSELF. ACADEMIC
PARTNERS TO INDUSTRY TO CREATE
THE SAFEST ENVIRONMENT FOR
PATIENTS. AND THE BEST POSSIBLE
OUTCOMES. THE BBMP TEAM IS
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OTHER
INDUSTRY PARTNERS TO CONSIDER
SCOPE OF PRACTICE ISSUES.
INCLUDING THE BEAUTIFICATION
MARKET TELEHEALTH AND ITS PLACE
IN NURSING EDUCATION AND
PROVIDING OF NURSING EDUCATION
USING NONTRADITIONAL METHODS
FOR EDUCATING ME AND STUDENTS.
THE BOARD CONTINUES TO WORK ON
OTHER SPECIFIC DEFICITS
INCLUDING SCHOOL APPROVAL TIMES
SCOPE OF PRACTICE ISSUES AND
RESOLVE OUR OUTSTANDING
DISCIPLINARY ISSUES. THIS BOARD
HAS A COMMITMENT TO CONSUMER
SAFETY AND THE WELFARE OF
PATIENTS THEIR COLLEGIAL AND
RESPECTFUL TO EACH OTHER AND
THOSE WITH WHOM THEY INTERFACE.
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE BOARD
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
CONSUMER THE CONSTITUENTS AND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WORKED
CLOSELY TO DEVELOP DEVELOP AND
CREATE HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL. COMMENTS IN
YOUR OPENING REMARKS FROM THE
BOARD. K. Z. S. C. NONE OF THEM
OF. IN THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IF
THERE ARE ANY INITIAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. WE
CAN OF- DOCTOR PAN FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR. I THINK
THE REMOTE AND- APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION I DID HAVE A
QUESTION- REGARDING- S. THAT
CONTINUING EDUCATION- WELL IT'S
A- IN THE OF THE SUBSCRIPTION-
WASN'T CLEAR AS TO HOW YOU
MONITOR IF SOMEONE'S TAKING THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION THEY NEED-
I UNDERSTAND FROM THE REPORT
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT YES
THERE'S AN EFFORT AUDIT
EVERYONE AND WHICH WAS NOT.
PARTICULARLY SUCCESSFUL ARE WS
SOSOMEWHAT PROBLEMATIC BUT
CERTAINLY OTHER BOARDS DO WHAT
THEY DO THEY AUDIT CERTAIN
PORTION OF THE LICENSEES EVERY
CYCLE. AS WAY TO MONITOR SO- SO
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT AND THEN
I THINK THIS SPORT ALSO DOES
PLAY A ROLE AND APPROVING C. AS
WELL. AND SO IF YOU CAN SPEAK
TO THE TYPES OF STANDARDS ARE
WHAT DO YOU YOU KNOW IT TO
ENSURE THAT THE C E. IS A OF
SUFFICIENT QUALITY MOST
SPECIFICALLY- DO YOU HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST POLICY AND
THIS IS SOMETHING I'VE ASKED
EVERY BOARD THAT MIGHT THAT THE
PROCEED TO ENSURE THAT. ANY
CONTINUE EDUCATION DAY THE
BOARD DOES APPROVE IS TRULY
CONTINUING EDUCATION IS NOT A
MARKETING OPPORTUNITY TO SELL
PARTICULAR PRODUCT OR SERVICE-
TO THE LICENSEES ARE THE
PATIENTS THEY TAKE CARE OF SO.
THAT THERE'S A SUFFICIENT
COMMON INTEREST POLICY- THAT
CAN BE APPLIED TO- TO SEE
THAT'S APPROVED BY THE BOARD TO
ENSURE THAT- THERE ARE.
CONFLICTS BETWEEN A PERSON
WHO'S TEACHING AT AND- AND FOR
PATIENT SELF KEY ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES REGARDING. CONTINUE
EDUCATION THANK YOU. I'D TO
DEFER THAT IS DUMB GOOD SHE-
OFFICER. THANK DR MOUNTAIN
THANK YOU SO UNDERSTAND- AFTER
THE C. ON IT UNDER PER MAN- THE
BOARD KIND OF TOOK A PAUSE AND
RESEARCHED AND ANALYZED WHAT AN
APPROPRIATE C. AUDIT PROGRAM
WOULD LOOK LIKE WE LAUNCH THAT
PROGRAM WHICH WE THOUGHT WAS
VERY SUSTAINABLE AND STILL. GOT
THE RESULTS WE WERE LOOKING FOR
IT SELECTED ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF PERCENT. OF OUR RENEWING
POPULATION ON IT THAT WAS ABOUT
ELEVEN HUNDRED LICENSEES OVER
THE COURSE OF. THE ALMOST YEAR
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO AUDIT-
ONLY ABOUT FIFTY CITATIONS WERE
ISSUED FOR NON COMPLIANCE WHICH
WE THOUGHT WAS WAS REMARKABLY
GOOD- WE OF COURSE PAUSE OUR
AUDIT FOR DURING THE PANDEMIC-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. RESUMING IT
pEXPIRES SO WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW
THE LICENSEES TO CATCH UP ON
THEIR COMPLIANCE. NOW TO YOUR
OTHER POINT SIR- I. ACTUALLY
I'M NOT A 100% CERTAIN HOW TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION I'M PRETTY
CONFIDENT THAT WE DON'T- WE
DON'T REQUIRE THAT COMPETITION
POLICY- WE SHOULD BE IN TERMS
OF THE WAY THAT THESE ARE
MONITORED OR REGULATED ARE ANY
CZ EVALUATE VIA THE PROPOSED C.
PROVIDERS AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WHAT THEY'RE ASKING TO EDUCATE
ON FITS INTO THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE STANDS. THE VARIOUS
OTHER- PROFESSIONAL FIELDS BUT-
I AM AWARE THAT SOME. ENTITIES
LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IMPLEMENTED SPECIFIC
REGULATIONS TO DEVELOP THAT
KIND OF. A PROBATION- SO WE
WILL BE HAPPY TO LOOK INTO THAT
M. WE MAY BE ABLE TO REPLY MORE
FULLY- LATER BUT WILL CERTAINLY
PROVIDE SOME COMMENT- IN IN A
REPLY TO THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT- REPLY- I
WOULD THINK NO DATA I'M SURE
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
KNOW THAT I ACTUALLY ASK THIS
OF PRACTICALLY EVERY BOARD THAT
HAS C. E. AND SOME DO AND SOME
DOWN. SO I HOPE PERHAPS- THE
ANSWER TO PARTS OF PART OF THE
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION MAYBE
IS THAT WE SHOULD HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDER. MAYBE
DRAFTING SOME MODEL CONTINUING
L. CONSEQUENCES POLICY
REGARDING CONTINUING EDUCATION
THAT. THAT THAT DON'T HAVE
EXISTING POLICIES CAN ALWAYS
MODEL THERE'S AFTER SO THAT- OF
EVERY BOARD ISN'T TRYING TO
START FROM SCRATCH IT'S MAINLY
TO BE SURE THAT THERE'S
DISCLOSURE. OF YOU KNOW
FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE IS THAT
SOMEONE HAS IF THEY'RE
PROVIDING A EDUCATION COURSE
OF- WHAT WHAT- YOU KNOW WHAT
THE CONFLICTS MIGHT BE IF
THEY'RE BEING PAID BY CERTAIN
TYPES OF ENTITIES THAT MIGHT
HAVE A PARTICULAR INTEREST AND
OF COURSE- FIVE SOMETHING ALONG
THE LINES OF. THAT FEATURE THAT
THEIR- OKAY. WITHOUT GOING TO
HOLD THE TOLERATE YOUR
COMMITTEE- I THINK THERE ARE
SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO LOOK INTO
THAT SO I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ROOM THANK YOU FOR
CONSISTENCY DR PAN. SOME OF THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRS
AND I JUST HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS KIND OF ON THE
PROCESS OF GETTING CERTIFIED
FROM THE SCHOOLS PERSPECTIVE.
I'M IS THERE ANYTHING IN. IN
LAW WITH THE TIMELINE THE
BENCHMARK OR ANY IDEA THAT THE
SCHOOLS IN THE ASSURANCES THAT
THE SCHOOLS CAN HAVE. ON A
PROCESS AND A TIME LINE TO GET
CERTIFIED- THROUGH THE BOARD.
IS THERE ANYTHING LIKE THAT. IN
WRITING. ONCE AGAIN AS
YAMAGUCHI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DRESS UP PLEASE. THANK YOU TALK
ABOUT- AT THIS POINT IN TIME
THERE IS NOTHING IN OUR CODE
REYES THAT LAYS OUT. A SPECIFIC
TIME FRAME A SPECIFIC
GUARANTEED FOR. A PROCESS FOR
THE SCHOOLS TO BECOME-
CERTIFIED TO APPROVE RATHER TO-
BEGIN ACCEPTING STUDENTS- THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING INTO FOR A LONG TIME-
BUT IN THE INTEREST OF BREVITY
ONE OF MY PAUSE THERE. BECAUSE
I SENSE THAT THERE MAY BE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. NORTH I
THINK YOU WERE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK THERE BUT I DO HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. SO WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE LIKE A TIME
LINE AND I THINK IN IN THE
WORLD OF CODE THAT WE LIVE IN
AND CERTAINLY PRIOR TO COVERT
EVEN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHEN
IT COMES TO THAT ARE.
COMMUNITIES WHERE ACCESS IS A
TREMENDOUS ISSUE- WE HAVE THESE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE READY AND
WILLING TO TAKE. STUDENTS TO
GET THEM TRAINED UP TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND IT SEEMS LIKE THEY
WERE THE LANE FOR SOME SORT OF
REASON. AND IF SO IT'S GOOD
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON THAT BUT
I AM CURIOUS LIKE WHAT ARE YOU
WORKING ON IT IS IT A-
FINANCIAL THING IS OF THE
STAFFING THING LIKE WHAT IS THE
HOLD UP. ON GETTING OUR
STUDENTS ABLE TO BE TAUGHT IN
THESE PARTICULAR INSTITUTIONS.
IT'S ACTUALLY ALL THE ABOVE
SIR- ONE OF THE PRINCIPLE. WE
WILL CALL A BARRIER TO. CRUEL
BUT ONE OF THE LARGEST FACTORS
INVOLVED IN THE APPROVAL
PROCESS IS THE CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT- THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY INTRICATE PROCESS-
AS YOU KNOW YOU MAY KNOW THAT-
CALIFORNIA BOTH OF US IN THE
BRN. OUR CURRICULUM AND
REQUIREMENTS. IT IS QUITE A BIT
MORE STRINGENT M. AND LARGER
THAN MOST OF THE OTHER STATES-
THIS IS OLD AND AGAIN I WILL.
CERTAINLY ADMIT THAT IT TAKES A
LONG TIME I THINK GENERALLY
SPEAKING- FROM THE TIME OF A
SCHOOL PROGRAM. SENDS A LETTER
OF INTENT TO THE TIME THAT IS
ACTUALLY ACCEPTING STUDENTS IS
WELL IN EXCESS OF TWO YEARS AND
I REALIZE THAT THAT IS NOT-
GOOD- RIGHT NOW I THINK THE-
THERE IS THE STAFFING ISSUES
THAT- ALREADY SEES WE HAVE SIX
ANY SEASON ONE SUPERVISING. NEC
AND THEIR WORK IS SPLIT UP
AMONG THE WORK WITH A LOT AT
THE ACTIVE SCHOOLS- WHICH LAST
YEAR WAS A VERY VERY LARGE
WORKLOAD. AND THEN ALSO TAKING
ON- I THINK THREE OR FOR EACH
OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS ON
PROPOSAL LIST IT TAKES A WHILE
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION THAT. THEY NEED TO
IT AND ADELINE AND WORK WITH
THAT PROPOSING PROGRAM IS
ENORMOUS AND VERY DENSE VERY
VERY COMPLEX AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF LOCAL FACTORS
ACADEMIC FACTORS. SO IT'S NOT A
PERFECT SYSTEM SO ONE OF THE
FACTORS WE DID DO WHEN YOU
MENTION THIS OF COURSE AS WELL
IS THAT THERE IS A FINANCIAL
ISSUE- ONE B. SOURCE LESS. WE
HAVE THE BOOK THE UNDERSTANDING
THE THEORY AT LEAST THAT SCHOOL
PROPOSED PROGRAMS. AND REALLY
AS A PLACE HLDER AND WERE THEY
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE UPFRONT
PROCESS YOU FEEL LIKE WE ARE
AND DOES. IT MAKE A- DELAY THEM
FROM PUTTING THEIR NAMES INTO
THE ON THE LIST UNTIL THEY'RE
MUCH FURTHER ALONG BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS I THINK WE WANT TO
LOOK AT AND THE BOARD AND THE
STAFF WILL BE. LOOKING THROUGH
A NUMBER OF SCENARIOS MOSTLY
HAVING TO DO WITH- KIND OF.
REEVALUATING AND MAKING STAGES
AND PHASES OR IN THE APPROVAL
PROCESS MAYBE PROVIDING MORE OF
A TRIAGE OR PRE APPROVAL
PROCESS- THERE'S A NUMBER OF
OPTIONS OPTIONS WE WANT TO
EXPLORE HERE- BUT ALL AIMED AT
THE IDEA OF. GETTING PROGRAMS
pTIME REMEMBER THAT. OUR PRIMARY
MISSION OF COURSE IS CONSUMER
SAFETY- WE MUST MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
APPROVED. ARE QUALIFIED AND
ARE. WELL STAFFED THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO ALL THE CRITICAL
RESOURCES- CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
FACULTY FACILITIES- SO LIKE I
SAID IT'S A VERY INTRICATE
PROCESS. BUT- WE'D CERTAINLY BE
WERE VERY WELCOMING TO. INPUT
FROM THE MEMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. THANK YOU. NO
I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR CANDOR
QUITE FRANKLY AND I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERNS AND I CERTAINLY
HAVE JOTTED A FEW NOTES DOWN
AND CAN SEE HOW SOME OF YOUR
ISSUES- COULD BE VERY VERY
DETRIMENTAL TO DOING YOUR JOB.
I JUST DO WANT TO SAY THAT ON
THE ON THE SCHOOL PERSPECTIVE I
THINK IF THERE WAS A WAY. THAT
WE COULD GIVE THEM SOME SENSE
OF A PROCESS A TIMELINE. IT
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO PLAN AS
WELL EVEN THOUGH YOU FOLKS ARE
WORKING THROUGH YOUR PROCESSES
AND DOING EVERYTHING THAT YOU
NEED TO DO ON YOUR END. I FEEL
LIKE WE SHOULD GIVE THEM THAT
SAME LEVEL OF COMFORT AS WELL
BECAUSE HERE THEY ARE JUST OUT
THERE IN EITHER KIND OF NOT
KNOWING WHEN AND WHERE THEY ARE
THEY CAN START UP. SO I THINK
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A DOUBLE
EDGED SWORD I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF SOME OF OUR-
SENATE ROTH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU KNOW I- COME OUT OF
THE MILITARY IN THE MILITARY WE
HAVE LOTS OF METRICS AND WE
USED TO SAY WHAT GETS MEASURED
GETS DONE AND TO FOLLOW ALONG
WITH THE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE ASSEMBLY IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IN THE IN THE
SCHOOL APPROVAL PROCESS AND IN
OTHER AREAS- WE NEED SOME SORT
OF- INTERNAL TIME TARGETS YOU
DO ANYWAY IN ORDER TO MEASURE
PERFORMANCE. AND SO I WOULD
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE YOU- TO
DEVELOP SOME SORT OF INTERNAL.
SCHEME OF METRICS WERE YOU SET
TIME TARGETS AT VARIOUS POINTS
IN PROCESS WHETHER IT'S- SCHOOL
APPROVAL OR- ONE OF THE OTHER
FUNCTIONS THAT THE BOARD
PERFORMS. SO YOU KNOW HOW TO
MEASURE THE PERFORMANCE OF YOUR
OWN TEAM. AND UNLESS YOU IN
WHICH I AS I UNDERSTAND IT YOU
MUST NOT HAVE THOSE TARGETS
EXCEPT IN THE AREA OF
DISCIPLINE AND ENFORCEMENT. AND
IF NOT THEN I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT YOU SET THEM. AND THAT
SIZE INTO THE QUESTION I HAVE
ABOUT FISCAL ISSUES AND- THE
BOARD AND AT LEAST IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPERS THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED RAISES CERTAIN.
QUESTIONS ABOUT YOUR CURRENT
FISCAL SITUATION. AND MY
QUESTION GOES TO SCHOOL
APPROVAL AND WILL REQUIRE AND
YOU REFERENCED A BILL
REQUIRING. SCHOOLS TO PAY A FEE
FOR APPROVAL RESOLVE THE
BOARD'S. FISCAL CONCERNS
ENTIRELY OR ARE THERE OTHER
ISSUES- THAT IMPACT YOUR FISCAL
OUTLOOK. I AM GOING TO TURN
THIS OVER TO MS YAMAGUCHI BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
ADDRESS THE IDEA THAT SCHOOLS
WILL NEED TO PAY A FEE. THAT
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING PUT
THEIR FEE STRUCTURE IN PLACE.
IT'S BEEN PROBABLY FOUR YEARS
AGO NOW AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IT HAS DONE IS. TO HELP
DIRECTORS LIKE MYSELF TO
RECOGNIZE WHEN WE WANT TO MAKE
CURRICULAR CHANGES THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS IN A
PACKAGE WE SUBMIT THAT PACKAGE
AND THEN THE NEC'S. CAMELBACK
PAPERWORK ONE TIME INSTEAD OF
PEOPLE SUBMITTING CHANGES MAYBE
MULTIPLE TIMES DURING THE YEAR
WHICH IS VERY TIME CONSUMING
PROCESS THOSE AND IT DOESN'T
BENEFIT THE SCHOOLS. OR AND
THEY THEY WORK ON THE BBMP
TEETH SO FOR MYSELF PERSONALLY
AS A DIRECTOR I. DON'T SEE- I
DON'T SEE ANY NEGATIVE TWO.
ENFORCING SOME FEES ON THE
SCHOOLS INCLUDING MY OWN SCHOOL
WHICH IS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
THE REST OF THE QUESTION OVER
TO MS YAMAGUCHI. KEEP
DOCUMENTED THANK YOU SENATOR-
THERE ARE OTHER FACTORS
INVOLVED IN OUR OUR FISCAL
HEALTH ONE OF WHICH OF COURSE
IS THAT THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS INCREASED OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS- AND
ACTUALLY I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
FAIR TO SAY THAT THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS INCREASED- WELL
OVER FIVE OR SIX YEARS AGO. M.
BECAUSE THE BOARD HAD A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL- STAFFING VACANCY
RATE THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF SALARY SAVINGS WHICH
ENABLED THE BOARD TO CONTINUE
FUNCTIONING AND THEN WHEN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN WE STARTED
HERE- AND WHAT OUR FIRST
PRIORITY OF COURSE WAS. TO MAKE-SURE THAT WE HAVE FULL STAFF
AND A FULL MANAGEMENT TEAM-
THOSE STATES- SALARY SAVINGS
WENT AWAY- WE TRY TO BE AS
FRUGAL AS WE POSSIBLY CAN OF
COURSE I THINK MOST OF. OUR
TEAM WILL VOUCH FOR THE FACT
THAT WE ARE AS FRUGAL AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN WE INVESTIGATED A
NUMBER OF FACTORS VERY WASTEFUL
SPENDING THAT- PREVIOUS
MANAGEMENT ENGAGED IN. ALL OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN CORRECTED AT
THIS POINT- AND- ALL. OF THE
PANDEMIC. DIGITAL US TO MAKE A
VERY SHORT TERM SAVINGS IN AND
TRAVEL COSTS THE BUT I THINK
THE KEY HERE IS THAT. THE
FUNDING STREAM THE REVENUE
STREAM NEEDS TO BE STABILIZED
IT NEEDS TO BE. BROUGHT UP TO
THE POINT WHERE IT IS
SUSTAINING THE BOARD'S
OPERATION AND IDEALLY CREATING
A PRUDENT RESERVE WE THINK-
WE'RE TOLD ANYWHERE BETWEEN
THREE TO SIX MONTHS OF A
RESERVE. IS THE DESIRED. FIGURE
WE HAVE A WAYS TO GO BEFORE
THAT. THANK YOU CENTER WELL I
DON'T I'M NOT BEING NEGATIVE ON
CONSIDERING A SCHOOL APPROVAL
FEE I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S CLEAR ON THE RECORD. I
JUST THINK THAT- THE IMPOSITION
OF A OF A FEE ON THE SCHOOL
IMPROVEMENT APPROVAL PROCESS IS
CERTAINLY GOING TO RAISE THE
BAR AND PUBLIC'S EXPECTATIONS
SO IT WILL MPHASIZE EVEN MORE
THE QUESTIONS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY ASKED ABOUT
INTERNAL- TIME LINES AND
GUIDELINES FOR PROCESSING
BECAUSE I THINK- YOU WILL BE
HELD TO A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
STANDARD. WHEN SCHOOLS HAVE TO
PAY MONEY IN ORDER TO
POTENTIALLY SECURE APPROVAL
FROM YOU AND TERMS OF
PROCESSING LET ME MOVE ON TO
ANOTHER METRICS ISSUE AND
THAT'S A FORMAL DISCIPLINE
TIMELINES- AND OF COURSE. THE
TARGET FOR FORMAL DISCIPLINE.
WAS MY UNDERSTANDING IS ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED WHAT FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY DAYS EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
COMPLETE THE FORMAL DISCIPLINE
PROCESS- THROUGH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S PROCESS. AND OF
COURSE YOU THIS BOARD AMONG
MANY MANY OTHERS- IS NOT
MEETING THAT TARGET. AND JUST
TO REFERENCE A LINE IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPERS BECAUSE PM
FOR WHICH I GUESS IS THIS
DISCIPLINE METRIC THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. DOES NOT TRACK
CASES BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF
TIME SPENT AT ANY GIVEN AGENCY
IT IS DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY THE
SOURCE OF POTENTIAL DELAYS
SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS NEEDS TO
CHANGEWE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MEASURE. THE TIME AT THE CA THE
TIME IT THAT YOUR BOARD THE
TIME AT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SHOP TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
BOTTLENECK IS AND WHERE THE
FAILURE TO MEET THAT FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY DAY. FORMAL
DISCIPLINE TIMELINE IS SO WE
CAN HELP YOU HELP YOURSELF AND
FIX IT IS IT POSSIBLE TO BREAK
THAT DOWN SO WE HAVE SOME
METRICS AT THE VARIOUS POINTS
IN TIME IN THIS FORMAL
DISCIPLINE PROCESS. AND HOW DO
WE DO THAT. YOU HAVE A GOOD SHE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND.
THANK YOU DR MOUNTAIN THANK YOU
THE QUESTION SIR- THAT IS A
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY. A GREAT
IDEA- ACTUALLY IT'S JUSTIN THE
PAST FEW MONTHS- THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ACTUALLY PASSED. THE
DIVISION OF INVESTIGATIONS TO
WORK WITH. THE BOARDS TO.
REALLY MAP OUT THE PROCESSES
AND THE- WHAT IS OF THE FACTOR
IN AGING AND BE ABLE TO TRACK
AS YOU SAY FROM STAGE TO STAGE
BECAUSE- I KNOW AND I KNOW FOR
OUR BOARD AND I'M- I BELIEVE
FOR PROBABLY MOST OF THE OTHER
BOARDS. THAT THINGS COME INTO
OUR OUR- ENFORCEMENT UNIT AND
THEY LEAVE FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE OR DO YOU BY.
VERY TIMELY- CERTAINLY WITHIN A
PARAMETER. BUT BUT CERTAIN
CERTAIN THINGS KIND OF CREATE
LAGS- OVER THE PAST YEAR I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT-
JUST AS LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE LOCAL COURTS. HAVE SORT
OF SHUT DOWN OR AT LEAST SLOWED
THEIR OPERATIONS THE- THE
CRITICAL FACTOR OF. OBTAINING
THE PROPER DOCUMENTS HAS BEEN
DRAMATICALLY SLOW SO
UNFORTUNATELY. PARDON ME.
PARDON ME- UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THIS UP CYCLE RUNS WERE
PROBABLY LOOKING THAT THIS
LASTING FOR A BIT BEFORE WE CAN
ACTUALLY REALLY START SEEING
THAT TEND REVERSED BUT AS I
SAID- THE DEPARTMENT DIVISION
OF INVESTIGATION. ARE
ABSOLUTELY ADDRESSING THIS AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF HOPE THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO CERTAINLY-
BREAKOUT PROCESS AND FIGURE OUT
WHERE THOSE BOTTLENECKS REALLY
ARE IN ONE OF THE CONTRIBUTING
CAUSES THERE THANK YOU. WELL
GOOD PERHAPS YOU CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT THE RECORDS THAT YOU DO
HAVE IN THE RECORDS THAT YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO IN THE OTHER-
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES INVOLVED IN
THIS PROCESS AND PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEES- SOME INFORMATION AS
TO. HOW LONG IT TAKES AT THESE
VARIOUS STAGES IN THE FORMAL
DISCIPLINE PROCESS AND IF YOU
CAN'T DO THAT LET'S AT LEAST
IDENTIFY WHAT YOU NEED TO DO IN
THE FUTURE SO THAT. THE NEXT
TIME WE CALL FOR DATA WE CAN
GET A REPORT ON THIS AND- THEN
TRY TO GO ABOUT. MAKING THIS
PROCESS A LITTLE MORE-
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE SINCE
YOU'RE DOING SO WELL IT LOOKS
LIKE. MADE TREMENDOUS
IMPROVEMENTS IN OTHER AREAS I
THINK WE NEED TO WE GOT A BILL
TO WORK ON THIS ONE AS WELL.
THANK YOU LET ME SHIFT WITH THE
CHAIRS PERMISSION LET ME SHIFT
TO ONE FINAL QUESTION AND ONE
FINAL AREA. AS YOU AS YOU
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. IN HEALTHCARE
TRAINING PROGRAMS- HAVE BECOME
AN ISSUE SORT OF ACROSS THE
BOARD. IN RECENT YEARS
CERTAINLY IN THE NURSING FIELD-
ALL ALL OVER. AND I WONDER IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS CLINICAL
PLACEMENT ISSUES- FOR THOSE
STUDENTS IN THE PIPELINE UNDER
THE- JURISDICTION OF YOUR
BOARD- BOAST THREE PANDEMICS.
AND DURING THE PANDEMIC. IS
THAT A FAIR QUESTION.
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ASKING IT- I THINK
I'LL START AND THEN I'LL
DEFERRED TO YOU- NEWS FROM A
GOOD YOU AGAIN BY CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS- FOR ALL OF NURSING
IS A HUGE ISSUE DO YOU AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT IS BEING PUT
FORWARD IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA
IS WE HAVE A COALITION WHERE
DIRECTORS OF PROGRAMS NURSING
PROGRAMS AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS.
AND THE BOARD'S WORK TOGETHER
TO ENSURE THAT THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS ARE AVAILABLE TO
NURSING STUDENTS IN A FAIR WAY
SO THAT NOT ONE PROGRAM HAS ALL
THE PLACEMENTS AND THE
COOPERATION THAT'S HAPPENED IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA THAT IS
SPREADING TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE AS WE LOOK AT- OTHER
METHODOLOGIES AS WELL TO.
CERTAINLY CONSIDERING THINGS
LIKE SIMULATION WHICH HAS BEEN
WITH US FOR ABOUT THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS- TELEHEALTH
ANOTHER THING THAT'S ON THE
DOCKET AND RIGHT NOW I KNOW
THAT NURSING STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE
VACCINATION PUSH ROLLOUT AND
THAT'S PROVIDING SOME CLINICAL
PLACEMENT AS WELL. AS YAMAGUCHI.
THANKS ON CENTER YOU'RE YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THAT
ACTUALLY THIS PROBLEM PRECEDED
THE PANDEMIC. BUT IN TWENTY
TWENTY WHEN VIRTUALLY ALL THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SITES CLOSED
DOWN WOULD NOT ALLOW STUDENTS
IN IT CREATED A VERY SUDDEN AND
VERY. SHARP CORPORATE CRISIS-
FOR THE SCHOOLS TO DEAL WITH
AND YOU KNOW AS A AS A SIDE
NOTE. THE MANY SEIZE DO THIS IS
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY THE NEC
SPEND SO VERY MUCH TIME WORKING
WITH THE PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY D HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES GOING FORWARD AND
THEY LOOK VERY CAREFULLY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SIT
FOR A SCHOOL TO SAY WELL WE
HAVE THESE PLACEMENTS- THEY
HAVE TO LOOK AT SEE WHERE THOSE
PLACEMENTS ARE AND THE STATE
WELL THE OTHER PROGRAM IN
RIVERSIDE LIST EXACT SAME
THINGS. IS THERE A PROBLEM HERE
SO IF YOU LIKE THIS IS A VERY
INTRICATE PROCESS BUT- TO MOVE
FORWARD I THINK- DR MOUNTAIN IS
100% CORRECT HERE THAT WE DO
HAVE TO LOOK AT A VARIETY OF
NEW WAYS TO PRODUCE- EXPERIENCE
FOR NURSING STUDENTS- BUT ALL
THE WHILE I THINK IT'S-
IMPORTANT I THINK OUR BOARD HAS
BEEN. VERY VERY STRONG IN THE
FACT THAT. SIMULATION
TELEHEALTH. AND OTHER OTHER
ROUGH EXPERIENCES ARE NOT A
SUBSTITUTE AND MAY NOT TAKE THE
PLACE OF A HUNDRED PERCENT. OF
THE CLINICAL DATA OUT
EXPERIENCE FOR THE STUDENTS
STUDENTS MUST WORK WITH LIFE
PATIENCE TO BE QUALIFIED
NURSES- THAT'S NOT. IN POLICY
THAT'S NOT A LONGER RACE BUT
IT'S ESSENTIAL AND I AND I
COULD FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
NINE OR BOARD DOES AS WELL.
WELL I'VE- LET ME JUST SAY THIS
I THINK- THE PROBLEM IS WE NEED
MORE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
CERTAINLY WE NEED MORE NURSES
AND THERE'S A FINITE NUMBER OF
TRAINING SITES AVAILABLE. SO
AND OF COURSE THERE UNDERSERVED
AREAS OF THE STATE TODAY THE
POPULATION OF THE STATE'S
GROWING THAT'S NOT GOING TO
MAKE THE UNDERSERVED AREAS FOR
PURPOSES OF HEALTH CARE ANY
BETTER OFF SO EITHER WE NEED
WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
IN TRAINING THAT ARE COMING OUT
OF THE PIPELINE OR KEEP IT THE
SAME OR WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT FAIRLY QUICKLY. HOW
WE PROVIDE THE ESSENTIAL
TRAINING TO THE INCREASED
NUMBER OF HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
WE NEED TO PRODUCE GIVEN THE
FACT THAT IT IS UNLIKELY WE'VE
DRAMATICALLY EXPANDED. THE
NUMBER OF PHYSICAL TRAINING
SITES THAT WE HAVE AROUND THE
STATE TO HANDLE THE DEMAND SO
IT SEEMS TO ME AND I WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR FROM YOU NOT TODAY
OBVIOUSLY BUT- AT SOME POINT AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
OF WHAT THE PLAN IS WHAT THE
SCHEDULE IS I NOTICED FROM THE
MATERIAL THAT YOU CONDUCTED A-
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
SIMULATION AS I RECALL IF I
READ IT CORRECTLY. AND WHAT THE
PRODUCT OF THAT IS- I REALIZE
YOU KNOW THE WAY WE'VE DONE
BUSINESS TO WAY WE DO IT TODAY
WE- WAY WE'VE DONE BUSINESS IN
THE PAST IS NOT TO RELY. AS
MUCH ON SIMULATION AND SOME OF
THESE OTHER. TECHNIQUES BUT-
TELEHEALTH FOR EXAMPLE BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO RE EXPLORE THAT IF WE-
ARE INTERESTED IN CRACKING THIS
NOT. AND THE NOT BEING HOW TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
TO THE UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE
STATE. GIVEN OUR LIMIT
LIMITATIONS FUNDING LIMITATIONS
FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION. BRICK AND
MORTAR FACILITIES AND THE LIKE
SO I CHALLENGE YOU TO DO THAT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO RECEIVING
THE INFORMATION THANK YOU
VENTURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SAYS IN A ROUGH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN FOLLOWED BY SIMPLY MEMBER
FALL. THANK YOU TRIMMING LOW
AND DETERMINE ROTH FOR THIS
HEARING AND FOR YOUR TIME.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT TO
THANK HIM IS THE LANGUAGE SHE
EVERY TIME I'VE INTERACTED WITH
HER. ON ISSUES OF MY DISTRICT
OR IN MY COMMUNITY SHE'S BEEN
EXTREMELY RESPONSIVE. AS WELL
AS APPROACHABLE ACCESSIBLE SO I
COMMEND YOU. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND ALL THE TIME BUT
YOU GIVEN- FOR MYSELF AND ALSO
SOME MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- AND
SEEKER GUIDANCE I NOTICED A
PART OF THOSE SCHOOL PROGRAM
APPROVAL PROCESS. REQUIRES A
NURSE EDUCATION CONSULTANT. TO
REVIEW THE APPLICATION AND FROM
MY UNDERSTANDING IT IS A LONG
PROCESS TO HIRING AND REPLACE
ANY SEES IF YOU WILL ON THE
MORE LEVEL. SO WHAT IT HELPS
ALLEVIATE FISCAL SHORTFALLS OF
THE BOARD AND SIMULTANEOUSLY
SPEED UP THE APPROVAL PROCESS
IF WE ALLOW A THIRD PARTY
AGENCY IF YOU WILL. TO HELP-
ADMINISTERED THE PROGRAM REVIEW.
DON'T MISS YAMAGUCHI DEFINITELY
TAKE THAT ONE. WELL FIRST OFF
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESEARCH HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PLEASURE TO TALK
TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF- THIS IS
A GREAT QUESTION FOR SO MANY
REASONS- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE STARTED TALKING ABOUT WHEN I
BURIED. MY VERY FIRST- MONTHS
HERE OF THE BOARD- NEC'S ARE
TREMENDOUSLY SKILLED EDUCATED
TRAINED- MOST OF THEM HAVE
ADVANCED DEGREES OF A FEW OF
OUR STAFF HAVE DOCTORS IN FACT-
IN YES THE RESOURCES ARE ARE
ARE PRETTY FINITE SO ONE OF
THINGS WE HAD BEEN LOOKING INTO
DISCUSSING IT INTERNALLY IS.
ARE THERE WAYS THAT WE CAN
STRETCH THAT RESOURCE ARE THERE
ARE WAYS THAT WE COULD EMPLOY
FOR EXAMPLE- ANALYSTS TO WORK
WITH THE NEC'S TO ENABLE THEM
TO COVER MORE GROUND. AND WE'VE-
FOUND MOSTLY THAT AND ANALYST
WOULD REQUIRE A VAST AMOUNT OF
TRAINING- TO BE ABLE TO. REALLY
HAVE THAT INSIGHT THAT ABILITY
TO FIND FLAWS ARE FINE-
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS IN IN FOR
EXAMPLE A SCHOOLS FACILITIES OR
CURRICULUM IT REALLY DOES
REQUIRE SOMEBODY WITH A GOOD
AMOUNT OF EXPERTISE. ONE THING
WE TALKED ABOUT- IN IN THIS
WOULD REQUIRE SOME SOME WITH
WITH CALLIE JAR IN THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD ONE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT WAS BEING ABLE TO.
HIRE AN IMPACT EMPOWER. ACTIVE
LICENSEES- VOCATIONAL NURSING
AND PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS TO
HELP PROVIDE THAT KIND OF A
RESOURCE THAT ON THE GROUND
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS THAT FACT
FINDING BECAUSE- AS AS
LICENSEES THEY BEEN THROUGH THE
PROGRAMS THEY WOULD KNOW WHAT
TO LOOK FOR. THEY WOULD
UNDERSTAND CERTAINLY FROM THEIR
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WHAT
WORKED AND WHAT WOULDN'T WORK-
THESE ARE WHAT THE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT I
THINK- BUT I DO WANT TO I DO
WANT TO SEE VERY. VERY FIRMLY
THOUGH THAT ARE NEC'S ARE
AMAZING AND WE'VE BEEN VERY
VERY FORTUNATE IN OUR TEAM- AT
THIS POINT TIME WE DO HAVE SIX
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE- WE'VE
LOST ONE LAST YEAR- SHE
RETIRED- BUT OUR TEAM IS VERY
UNIFIED IN VERY VERY.
EXPERIENCE AND INTERESTINGLY
THEIR EXPERIENCE IN A VERY
DIVERSE AREA SO WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHOSE EXPERTISE IS CURRICULUM
PEOPLE WHO. DID MORE FACULTY
MORE FACILITIES SO WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO I THINK STRUCTURE THAT.
BY HAVING KIND OF A- BUT A LEAD
IF YOU WILL. ON THAT FIRMANDO
MR TRUMP I APOLOGIZE BECAUSE
I'M NOT CERTAIN I'M GETTING ALL
THE FACETS OF YOUR QUESTION. NO
I THINK YOU'RE A ANSWERING TO
THE QUESTION APPROPRIATELY AND
IF I MAY- I DO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT ANOTHER SUBJECT IF THAT'S
RAIMES ALLERGY AND- MILLER
SUBJECT I SEE IS YOU HEAR NOT
ONLY FROM MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THE ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN TERMS OF A HOPE
AND A NEED TO EXPEDITE. THE
APPROVAL NURSING PROGRAM
PROCESS AND- THIS TEAM CHAIRMAN
ROB WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
INDIAN DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
PIPELINE. OF PRACTITIONERS TO
BE ABLE TO GET IN THE FRONT
LINES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
WE'VE HEARD ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THAT THERE COULD BE
ANYWHERE BETWEEN WAYS OF TO WIN
THREE YEARS- AND THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY OF PERHAPS- TAKING
AWAY SOME THE REDUNDANCIES WHAT
ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
REDUNDANCIES- ON THE BOARD
LEVEL TO SPEED UP THE APPROVAL
PROCESS TO ADDRESS. AS I
UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT BACKLOG-
IS THERE A PROCESS RIGHT NOW TO
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
REDUNDANCIES. I ASSUME YOU WANT
ME TO ANSWER THE STOCK AMOUNT.
MISTER CHENEY EXACTLY RIGHT
ONE- WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
SEVERAL JOURNALISM. FOR ONE
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT- IS IT
POSSIBLE TO SPLIT THE LIST AND-
HAVE A LIST FOR PRIVATE SCHOOLS
AND THEN A SEPARATE LIST FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND ALLOW US TO
ADDRESS THEM- SORT OF IN
TANDEM. WHICH- BECAUSE- PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND PRIVATE SCHOOL
PROPOSALS. VASTLY OUTNUMBERED
THE PUBLIC PROPOSALS AND THIS
WOULD ACCELERATE THE APPROVAL
OF THE PUBLIC PROGRAMS- ONE OF
THE THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT OF
COURSE WAS A- LOOKING INTO WAY
TO STAGE OUT THE APPROVAL
PROCESS. AND DO A LITTLE BIT
MORE INITIAL TRIAGE- WHEN THE
INITIAL PROPOSAL THE INITIAL
LETTER OF INTENT YEARS
RECEIVED- WE THINK THAT THAT
WOULD. THAT WOULD HELP I THINK
KIND OF. A FOCUS AND SO. AT
THAT POINT WE WOULD HAVE I
THINK OF MORE. TRIAGE
PRIORITIZE APPROVAL PROCESS- WE
WOULD REQUIRE RAKES FOR THIS- I
THINK THAT I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THAT- THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STEPS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO.
EXPLORE AND MOST WOULD REQUIRE
SOME SEVERAL MAKING ACTIVITY
WELL THE IDEAS THAT WE HAD
TALKED ABOUT I THINK A BIT.
WAS- THE VERY IDEA OF. ALLOWING
PROGRAM SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
MULTIPLE CAMPUSES- IF THEY'RE
USING EXACTLY THE SAME
CURRICULUM EXACTLY SAME
POLICIES. SHOULD THEY JUST HAVE
AN ACCELERATED APPROVAL
PROCESS. WHICH IS- A VERY
INTERESTING IDEA. EDIT IT WOULD
SUIT THE GOAL OF HAVING MORE
PROGRAMS OPEN AND MORE STUDENT
SEATS AVAILABLE QUICKLY. BUT
WHAT IT WOULD DO OF COURSE THAT
IS ALSO CREATE MORE OF- BUT
AWFULLY SYSTEM WHERE. THE
LARGER BETTER FUNDED PROGRAMS
DO. START TO ACQUIRE MORE OF A
PRESENCE AND- NOT NECESSARILY A
BAD THING I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME BECAUSE WE
DO WANT- PROGRAMS FROM
UNDERSERVED AREAS SMALLER
PROGRAMS- PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AFFILIATED WITH LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. IT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE EXPLORED CAREFULLY-
IN PERHAPS BUT AS YOU KNOW IT
IT'S A VERY LONG PROCESS TO
MAKE A DECISION LET ALONE TO
LAUNCH A NEW WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS- BUT IT THESE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS WE'VE
DISCUSSED DOING- AS I SAY. SOME
OF THEM YOUR BOARD CAN ACT ON
ON SOME SOME NOTIONS THAT CAN
HELP US TO BETTER PROCESS THAT
WAITING LIST AND THAT
APPLICATION TIME. HELLO I'M-
YOU SPOKE TO NO REDUNDANCIES IT.
YOU KNOW EXCESSIVE PROCESSES I
THINK- AND THAT IS FAIR I THINK
BECAUSE- AS I SAID I THINK
EARLIER. OF THE ONE OF THE-
MOST TIME CONSUMING. PARTS OF
THE PROCESS IS THE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL OF CURRICULUM. OF ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT WHICH PEOPLE EITHER LOVE
OR HATE. IS SHOULD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE A UNIFORM
CURRICULUM. AND THAT CHANGES
EVERYTHING- THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD CONSIDER AND I KNOW THAT
OUR BOARD WILL CERTAINLY BE
DISCUSSING. DR MOUNTED YOU WANT
TO ADD ANYTHING TO THAT. AND I
AM ABSOLUTELY 100% IN SUPPORT
OF THAT UNIFIED CURRICULUM
ACROSS THE STATE AND I THINK
THAT IT WOULD CERTAINLY ADDRESS
SEVERAL ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP TO DATE AND IF
THERE'S UNIFIED CURRICULUM THEN
THE CLINICAL USAGE WILL BE.
MORE EQUITABLE ACROSS THE BOARD
AND PROGRAMS COULD WORK MORE
COOPERATIVELY AND SO THAT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING. THAT I AS
A BOARD PRESIDENT OF SUPPORT
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE REST OF
THE BOARD IS ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO
CONSIDERING. A GERMAN LOS
AMASSED ONE FINAL QUESTION
CHAIRMAN ROTH AS WELL- AND
OFFER GO THE REST OF MY
QUESTIONS- THIS IS BEEN VERY
INSIGHTFUL- I WANTED TO. TAKE
YOU BACK ON MY STEAM CALLING
FOR RIPPON'S QUESTION AND- HE
STATED THAT- SOME OF THE FOLKS-
THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS HE
SAYS IT GOES INTO THIS EITHER
THROUGH THAT APPROVAL
APPLICATION PROCESS. AND THEY
WILL GO TO YOUR DOCTOR BROWN
NOR- DIRECTOR- YOU LABEL G.
AND- ASK YOU WHERE'S THE
PROCESS GOING WHERE ARE WE- AND
FOR YOUR MEMBERS AND STAFF. AS
WELL AND- IN THE EFFORT FOR
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS PANDEMIC TO HAVE A
CUSTOMER FRIENDLY TYPE OF
SERVICE BASED ADMINISTRATION-
WE'VE WE GET SOMETHING ON THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SIDE- AND I HAD
OTHER MEMBERS- SAY SOMETHING
SIMILAR- WE SEE SOMETHING IN
PROCESS. CLINICAL PACKAGE
RECEIVED PACKAGE DELIVERED
PACKAGE. YET IN PROCESS FROM A
TO B. IS THERE SOMETHING IS
THERE SOMETHING IN WHICH ONE A
PROCESS GOES THROUGH-
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS CAN BE
TREATED AS A CUSTOMER WHERE
THEY SAY OKAY HERE'S MY
APPROVAL PROCESS THIS IS WHERE
IT IS AT THIS STAGE AT THIS
POINT. AND AT THE GET A AT
LEAST AN IDEA OF WHERE IT IS AS
OPPOSED. TO PERHAPS JUST.
PUTTING IT IN A PROCESS WHERE
THEY DO KNOW IT IS IT'S IT IN
LIMBO. IT IS SIX MONTHS AWAY
SEVEN MONTHS AWAY WHAT WHAT
INFORMATION DO THEY NEED TO
GIVE TO YOU TO TRY TO GET TO
WHERE THEY WANT TO GO BECAUSE I
THINK. CERTAINLY YOUR GOALS AND
THEIR GOALS ARE THE SAME THEY
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO RIDE
SERVICE- TO OUR FOR FORTY
MILLION RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
SO IS THERE A WAY IN WHICH WE
CAN GIVE THEM AT LEAST A TIME
LINE AS THEY GO THROUGH THIS.
OUR PROCESS OF. WHERE THEY ARE
IN THE SYSTEM. EVENIF- IT
EVEN. BETTER TO HAVE. A TIME
FRAME COMPONENT ADDED TO THAT.
THAT IS A THAT IS MY QUESTION
WITHOUT OFFER GO TO REST MY
QUESTIONS. COULD YOU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. ACTUALLY WE DO
EXACTLY THAT BUT IN A VERY
RUDIMENTARY AND VERY. VERY
RUDIMENTARY ALSO STATE WAY
WHAT- WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT. A
COUPLE TIMES A YEAR- OUR STAFF
WILL LOOK AT THE- THE WAITING
LIST AND THEY'LL CONTACT THE
FOLKS WHO MADE THE PROPOSAL-
USUALLY WE HAVE ASKED. YOUR
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN ON THE LIST
WE THINK IT'S PROBABLY GONNA BE
ANOTHER YEAR BEFORE AN NEC IS A
SIGN YOUR PROGRAM DO YOU WANT
TO STAY ON THE LIST- IN SOME
CASES WHEN WE- NOT BEEN ABLE TO
FIND AND CONTACT. THE PEOPLE
PROPOSING THEM WE OF COURSE.
EXERCISE A LITTLE BIT OF A
PATRICIAN PRUNING OF THE LIST
THERE WHICH DEBT BUT IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN VERY OFTEN- I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT. WHAT WE DO
PROVIDE IS WHAT WE CAN PROVIDE
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE AS I
SAID. IN TILL IT REACHES A
CERTAIN OINT ON THE LIST AND
RIGHT NOW IT'S YOU KNOW. ONCE
YOU GET TO BE SOMEWHERE ABOUT.
BETWEEN I THINK TEN AND TWENTY-
YOU'RE WAITING. AND THERE'S NOT
MUCH YOU CAN DO ALTHOUGH WE DO
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT YOU
PEOPLE WORKING UNDER YOUR
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES IN YOUR
CURRICULUM. BUT THERE'S NOT A
WAY TO SAY. YOUR SIX MONTHS OUT
YOUR TEN MONTHS OUT YOUR TWO
YEARS OUT. WITH ANY DEGREE OF
ACCURACY BECAUSE THE PROCESS
ITSELF IS SORT OF VERY.
INCONSISTENT DOESN'T REALLY
WORK I WANT BUT- IT VERY SO
STRONGLY FROM FROM PROGRAM TO
PROGRAM. AND UNFORTUNATELY. I'M
A BIG PART OF THAT VARIANCE HAS
TO DO WITH THE PEOPLE INVOLVED
WHEN THEY DON'T REPLY IN A
TIMELY MANNER OR THEY SUBMIT-
OF INACCURATE INCOMPLETE
INFORMATION THAT THE NEC STARTS
TO REVIEW. AND THEN RETURNED
SAYING THANK YOU THAT'S GREAT
BUT YOU'RE MISSING PARTS THREE
FOUR FIVE AND THEN THEY SEND
THAT BACK IN THE PROPOSING BODY
CHáVEZ PART THREE BUT NOT
FOREIGN FIVE AND THERE'S A BACK
AND FORTH AND BACK AND FORTH
AND THAT DOES ABSORB A VAST
AMOUNT OF TIME- ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT
WITH THEM. THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE STAFF IS. WE PROBABLY
SHOULD CREATE TIGHTER
TIMELINES- REQUIREMENTS THAT IF
YOU DON'T RESPOND WITHIN SIX
WEEKS SIX DAYS- YOU GO ON AN
INACTIVE YOU GO SOME BUT YOU
KNOW BASICALLY YOU LOSE YOUR
PLACE IN LINE ARE YOU GO TO AN
ACTIVE WE WOULD NEED A DESIGN-
STRUCTURE LIKE THAT. AGAIN THIS
WOULD ALMOST CERTAINLY REQUIRE
WILL MAKING- BUT THERE'S A
THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ALTERNATIVES AND- AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT YOU IN
THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
SAYING THAT. CERTAINLY IT WOULD
BE FAIR AND IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO. OF I
THINK IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNICATIONS AND TRANSPARENCY.
THANK YOU. VIDYALAYAM OF WORK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FOLLOWED
BY A DOCTOR PAN AND THEN
SENATOR ROTH. BUT THEY DID WAS
CHAIR- I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON. A FEW ITEMS MAYBE DIVE
DEEPER WITH THE SENATE CHAIR
HAD MENTIONED AND ALSO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIP AND- SAID
THESE SCHOOLS HAVE TO BE
ACCREDITED- FOR EDUCATIONAL
QUALITY AND WHICH IS EXTENSIVE
APPROVAL PROCESS AND THEN
SEPARATELY. THAT THERE'S
ANOTHER APPROVAL PROCESS THAT
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH. WITH
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. SO
ANOTHER EXTENSIVE- PROCESS AND
IT SEEMS O ME THAT. AS YOU AND
I INDICATED THAT THERE IS
ALREADY AN EXTENSIVE TIME LINE-
OR ACTUALLY WERE TRYING TO SET
UP A TIME LINE- SO. WHY IS
THERE A NEED FOR. TO PROCESS
THESE. FOR PRIVIL GE. SHE FOR
CALLING THE- THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE SECONDARY LOOK AT A
PROGRAM BASED ON ITS ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE ITS FISCAL
HEALTH YEAH- IT STE
INSTITUTIONAL IF YOU WILL AND
OUR FOCUS IS SPECIFIC TO THAT
THE ACADEMIC PROGRAM INVOLVED
SO THE TO SORT OF DOVETAIL
TOGETHER. THERE IS NOT. AN
APPRECIABLE AMOUNT OF
REDUNDANCY BUT WHEN ISSUES DO
CROP UP FOR EXAMPLE ACOUPLE
YEARS AGO I THINK A LOT OF YOU
ESPECIALLY. THOSE OF YOU IN THE
SAN DIEGO LOS ANGELES AREA
REMEMBER THAT WE HAD A
SITUATION WHERE THE SCHOOL
ABRUPTLY CLOSED ITS DOORS AND-
WE HAD TO SCRAMBLE AND WE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
BUREAU. TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WAS A TEACH OUT THAT THE
STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO FINISH
THEIR PROGRAMS DESPITE THE- THE
PROGRAM ITSELF RUN OFF. SO WE
DO WORK WELL TOGETHER WE
COMMUNICATE ON ON THE ISSUES I
THINK WE SHARE INFORMATION-
VERY WELL. HE ACTUALLY USED TO
BE MY UPSTAIRS NEIGHBORS IT WAS
A LOT EASIER TO RUN UPSTAIRS
BUT- I THINK I THINK WE FOUND-
THAT WE WORK WELL TOGETHER I
THINK OF. OUR NURSES GEN
ESPECIALLY ARE SUPERVISING
NURSING. EDUCATION CONSULTANT.
HAS BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE. A LOT
OF DIALOGUE BACK AND FORTH
WHERE WE SHARED. NOT JUST THE
INFORMATION ON CURRENT
SITUATIONS BUT THE WAY WE DO
BUSINESS- WOULD IT BE BETTER TO
HAVE A SINGLE ENTITY. POSSIBLY
POSSIBLY BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO REALLY
EVALUATE- IT'S FISCAL HEALTH
FOR EXAMPLE- THAT WOULD REQUIRE
SOME VERY DEEP ANALYSIS AND HE
DOES NOT HAVE THE- CAPABILITIES
TO EVALUATE WHETHER THAT
NURSING PROGRAM AT THAT SITE
CHECK PROGRAM MEETS ALL THE
CRITERIA AND HOW AND WHY. SO
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE PROCESS
IS NOT DIFFICULT THEREOF OR
THAT THERE ARE THERE THERE IS
DUPLICATION IN THE INTERVIEW
PROCESS HE'S. I'M SORRY MR FONG
THE SOUND CUT IN AND OUT ON THE
OR ARE YOU SAYING THAT THERE IS
NO DUPLICATION IN THE PROBLEM
THE TO PROCESS THESE OR- ARE
YOU SAYING THAT THERE IS
DUPLICATION THAT NEEDS TO BE.
HAMMERED OUT. I DON'T THINK
THERE'S DUPLICATION I THINK
THERE AREAS THAT WE- MUST WORK
TOGETHER TO DO. THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S
DUPLICATIVE SO I'M I'M I'M
READING THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS
PROVIDED BY THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND IT INDICATES THAT- THE
BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. AND
OTHER PRIVATE INSTITUTIONAL
PROGRAM MAKE THE CREDITORS THEY
ARE APPROVED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
TREATED SHE THAT RECOGNITION
YOU HAVE TO ESTABLISH
EXPECTATIONS REVIEW THE
FOLLOWING A GOOD CURRICULUM
FACULTY SUCCESS AND STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT. FACULTIES
EQUIPMENT SUPPLIES FISCAL IN A
MEASURE OF CAPACITY STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES RECRUITING
ANIMATION PRACTICES MEASURES A
PROGRAM LENGTH I MEAN THERE'S A
LIST OF TEN ITEMS. DO THOSE
ITEMS DO YOU REVIEW THOSE ITEMS
TO. IN YOUR PROCESS. YES AND NO
BECAUSE I THINK- ENOUGH AMOUNT
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IN THE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS-
OFTENTIMES AT LEAST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- THE CREDITORS WILL
LOOK. AT CURRICULUM AND EVEN
ISSUES REGARDING REVOLVING
AROUND THE ACADEMIC PROGRAM
ITSELF AND ESSENTIALLY A LOT OF
TIMES THEY WILL BASICALLY SAY.
MEETS THE BOARD'S CRITERIA AND
IS APPROVED BY THE BOARD AND
THEY CHECKED THE BOX- IN TERMS
OF UP TO SEE. AT YES. WE DO
THAT TO. DOES THE PROBE HAVE.
ADEQUATE AMOUNTS OF DESKS AT
AND COULD AT A LIVE. IS IT C.
IS A CLEAN. UP WE DO EXAMINE
THE FAST. AND THIS THING TO
IMPROVE SCHOOL. AND I DO KNOW
THAT- THAN A CREDITOR WILL BE
LOOKING AT THOSE FACTORS AS
WELL. I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR ANSWERS I JUST WOULD SAY
THAT- IT SEEMS TO BE THAT THERE
IS NEEDED IMPROVEMENT I THINK I
THINK EVERYONE HERE CAN SEE
THAT- THERE IS SOME DUPLICATION
I WOULD I WOULD VENTURE TO BET
THAT AN OBJECTIVE REVIEW. WITH
YOU THAT THERE IS- I WOULD ECHO
WHAT THE SENATOR SAID THERE IS
A NEED FOR. MORE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS- ESPECIALLY IN
THE AREA OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
WE HAVE AND THE PANDEMIC AS
REVEALED- THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES
THAT- I BELIEVE WE ALL KNOW HAS
EXISTED FOR A WHILE- INTO
WHETHER- THE PANDEMIC HAS
ACCELERATED THESE NEEDS WE'RE
CERTAINLY I THINK IS THE CASE
IS THE AND PUBLIC
UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE MORNING-
I THINK WE CERTAINLY DO NEED TO
LOOK AT- PUTTING. WE'RE
IMPROVING THE PROCESS
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE A OF AN
APPARENT BACKLOG OF FIFTY FOUR
SCHOOLS- THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
APPROVAL- FOLLOWING UP ON ON MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES THAT THAT.
THAT THE- THERE NEEDS TO BE-
TIMELINES AND- AND IMPROVEMENT
OF THE PROCESS SO THAT- THERE'S
THE NEED NO AND KNOWLEDGE OF
DEADLINES AND EVERYTHING ELSE
LIKE THAT- I THINK THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION PROVIDED
IN THE WORK TO BE DONE TO
IMPROVE THAT PROCESS SO. I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. K. THE YOU
A QUICK FOR BY PAN FOR A FALL
BY CENTER RON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ACTION MY QUESTION IS
ACTUALLY UP ALSO TO SOME
QUESTIONS THAT FROM CENTER ROTH
AND JUST FOR FULL DISCLOSURE I
MYSELF ACTUALLY SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF AN ACCREDITATION.
AGENCY AND- NATIONAL WONDER
TRADITION COUNSELING GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION. AND I MYSELF
ALSO WAS A DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION PROGRAM THOSE
ACCREDITED THERE FOR NEW WAS
LIKE TO HAVE TO. SUBMIT
PAPERWORK AND DOCUMENTS STUFF
FOR ACCREDITATION SO I'VE BEEN
ON BOTH SIDES. THE ISSUE AND
IT'S CERTAINLY ON- AT LEAST
HAVE SOME UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES THE BOARD HAS AND IN
THOSE ROLES RIGHT HAVING TO
PROVE PROGRAMS AND SO FORTH- SO
I GUESS THE- BRIEF COMMENT AND
THEN A QUESTION- THE COMMENT
IS- I KNOW AN ISSUE SIXTEEN
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS- AS A
BOARD- PROBABLY BUT CHALLENGED
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT REALLY IN A
ROLL OF FINDING CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT UNIQUE
CERTAINLY TO THIS PARTICULAR
PROFESSION. AND WE DO NEED TO
THINK ABOUT- FRANKLY- YOU KNOW.
HAVING TRAINEES COSTS MONEY FOR
ANY CLINICAL SITE ALL RIGHT I
MEAN I DID RESEARCH AND- AND
WORKFORCE AND THE COST OF
ACTUALLY TRAINING. IN AND
CLINICAL SITES AND DAY AT AND
SO OFTEN TIMES WE- EXPECT THE
CHARITY OF THE BUYER'S CLINICAL
SITES BUT THAT'S NOT WORKING
OUT EFFECTIVE MANY
UNFORTUNATELY MANY PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS. GET THEIR
CLINICAL SITE BY ACTUALLY
PAYING FOR THEM. WHICH ACTUALLY
DISADVANTAGES SOMETIMES PUBLIC
PROGRAMS- HOOCH MAY NOT HAVE
ITS NAY RESOURCES SO I THINK
JUST I WANTED PAN ON THAT FOR.
US TO CONSIDER IN TERMS OF.
WHAT WE DO IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING CLINICAL SITES ONLY
FOR THIS- PARTICULAR PROFESSION
BUT OTHERS THE QUESTION I HAVE
FOR YOU THOUGH IS THAT. I DO WE
TALK ABOUT DUPLICATION. BETWEEN
BETWEEN ACCREDITATION AGENCIES
IN THE BOARD'S ROLE. DOES THE%
BOARD IT'S AN AND YOU'D
MENTIONED ALSO ABOUT LOOKING AT
STANDARDIZED CURRICULUM AS WELL
AND- AND THE WORK BEHIND THAT
IT DOES THE- WHEN YOU- A-
SCHOOL. I'D DO YOU ACTUALLY GET
ALL THE DOCUMENTS TO THE SCHOOL
ALSO- BASICALLY DO YOU- THE
DOCUMENTS THEY HAVE TO SUBMIT
FOR ACCREDITATION DO CAN THEY
JUST SUBMIT THE SIMILAR SAME TO
DOCUMENT YOU MAY WANT TO
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON TOP
OF THAT BUT INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO HAVE TO HAVE YOUR OWN
VERSION OF THE SAME THING SO
BASIS SO IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
REDUCE THE- THE SORT OF
OVERHEAD. OF US SUBMITTING AN
APPLICATION AND THEN- IN TERMS
OF YOUR REVIEW PROCESS DO YOU
TAKE ACCOUNT OF WHAT THE
SCHOOLS HAVE TO SUBMIT TO OTHER
AGENTS OTHER ACCREDITING
BODIES. IN YOUR APPROVAL TO TRY
THIS AGAIN STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS FOR THE- FOR THE
SCHOOLS THEY'RE TRYING TO
SUBMIT. SOME ADULTS PAPERWORK.
I THINK I'LL GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF AN ANSWER THEN I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MS YAMAGUCHI HAVING
JUST BEEN THROUGH MIGHT BE
VNPT. ACCREDITATION PROCESS
DURING THE PANDEMIC LAST
SUMMER- THERE IS SOME OVERLAP
AND I DRAW FROM SO WE ARE
WATCHING ACCREDITED BECAUSE
WE'RE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHERE I
WORK- AND SO I AM ABLE TO DRAW
FROM SOME OF THOSE. DOCUMENTS
AND THEY DO FIT IN TO WHAT I
HAVE TO TURN IN. TO THE BBMP
TEAM BUT TRULY THE ACCREDITING
AGENCIES ARE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT THINGS ADDITIONALLY
IN NURSING THERE IS NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION CALLED HE SAID HE
C. N. THAT. THAT WAS A CREDIT A
CREDIT. THE END PROGRAM. AND
SOME HAVE CHOSEN TO GET THAT
ADDITIONAL NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION WHICH VERY MUCH
DUCK TALES WHAT THE BOARD.
LOOKS AT AND THEN IT'S VERY
EASY TO USE THOSE DOCUMENTS TO
CROSS OVER BUT TRULY THESE
ACCREDITING AGENCIES ARE
LOOKING AT SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT THE NEC IS
EVALUATING. WHEN THEY COME IN
AND ARE LOOKING AT VERY PROGRAM
SPECIFIC ISSUES. TO ENSURE THAT
NURSING NURSES ARE GRADUATING
WITH ADEQUATE INFORMATION TO
TAKE CARE OF PATIENTS AND IT'S
REALLY PROTECTING THE PUBLIC IN
THAT METHODOLOGY. MS YAMAGUCHI.
I DON'T THINK IT HAD ANYTHING
TO THAT. THANK YOU WELL I GUESS
I WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT- IT
MIGHT BE WORTH A CONVERSATION
WITH THE VARIOUS ACCREDITATION
AGENCIES I KNOW THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY YOU'RE LOOKING IS
ACTUALLY THE SAME THING BUT I
THINK WE'RE TERMS AGAIN TRYING
TO REDUCE DUPLICATION AND
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS- THAT-
THERE MAY BE SOME BENEFIT
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE-
HOW HOW THE TWO PROCESSES. WELL
YOU KNOW A LINER NOT A LINE AND
WHAT AND HOW DO WE THE FLOW OF
INFORMATION- THAT HAS TO HAPPEN
AND THAT EXPENSE RELATED TO
THAT AS WELL BOTH IN TIME AND-
MANPOWER MISTER MANPOWER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATE ROTH.
THANK YOU JUST A QUICK. FOLLOW
UP QUESTION TO THE QUESTION MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE ASEMBLY ASK
ABOUT TO SCHOOL APPROVALS. YOU
MENTIONED UNIVERSAL CURRICULUM
AND TO ME THAT- IF IMPOSE THAT
WOULD SEEM A BIT- POTENTIALLY
DISRUPTIVE ANYWAY IN IN IN THE
STATE. BUT WOULD THERE BE ANY
IMPEDIMENT FOR THE BOARD TO
ADOPT A COMMON CURRICULUM
COMMON POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
COVERING VOCATIONAL. NURSE
EDUCATION FOR EXAMPLE. THAT IF
A PROPOSED ADOPTED THOSE. THE
APPROVAL PROCESS WOULD BE MUCH
EXPEDITED. NOT REQUIRED BUT IF
ADOPTED A COMMON CURRICULUM.
COLIN POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
AS A SET. AND IF THE SCHOOL
SAID YES THAT'S FINE WITH US.
HOW MUCH TIME WOULD THAT CUT
OFF OF YOUR APPROVAL PROCESS.
AND WOULD THAT HELP TO REDUCE
THE BACKLOG. I AM GOING TO TURN
THIS OVER TO ME YOU HAVE A GOOD
YEAR BUT I DID WANT TO MENTION
THAT- THE STATE OF OREGON HAS
ALREADY INSTITUTED- AND- THE-
STATEWIDE CURRICULUM. AND THEY
DID IT- SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
IT'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
SCHOOLS CAN CHOOSE TO NOT BE
PART OF THAT. BUT I THINK THAT
IT HAS- DEFINITELY CONTRIBUTED
TO THEIR ABILITY. TO PRODUCE
WELL EQUIPPED NURSES TO COME
OUT INTO THE FIELD AND IT IS
ALSO PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT IF A STUDENT NEEDS TO MOVE
FROM ONE AREA TO ANOTHER WITHIN
THE STATE YOU'RE ABLE TO
TRANSFER IN THOSE PROGRAMS SO I
STATEWIDE CURRICULUM WOULD BE A
HUGE ADVANTAGE I THINK TO
STUDENTS AND TO CONSUMERS WHO
KNOW THAT THEIR- THEY ARE-
GETTING INTEREST IS TRAIN
THROUGH ITS METHODOLOGY- SO YES
IT WOULD BE A BIG UNDERTAKING.
BUT I THINK IN THAT THE LONG
TERM GAIN FOR NURSING AND FOR
THE PUBLIC WOULD BE HUGE
YAMAGUCHI. I THINK- MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK TEAR YOUR
QUESTION. WOULD IT SAVE TIME I
WOULD THINK IN THE IN THE LONG
RANGE YES IT WOULD- JUST
BECAUSE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT AS A AS A GIVEN AND
THEN. THE NEC'S WOULD BE ABLE
LOOK AT ALL THE OTHER FACTORS
INVOLVED ESPECIALLY THE MORE
REGIONALLY BASED ONES- THE
CHALLENGE OF COURSE IS THAT
SHORT TERM. IT WOULD DELAY THE
PROCESS BECAUSE WE WOULD NEED
TO- I WOULD NEED TO PROBABLY RE
ASSIGNED A STAFF PERSON TO
DEVELOP. YOU KNOW BASED ON ALL
THE BEST PRACTICES THT WE'VE
SEEN FROM. THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE DOING REALLY REALLY WELL
AND HAVE HISTORICALLY ALWAYS
DONE SO- AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE IS THE POINT THAT. I WOOD
AGAIN THIS WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
RULE MAKING. AND THAT IS.
PROBABLY A YEAR OR MORE OF A
PROCESS- LOOK I'M I'M
SUGGESTING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
CHOICE BUT- AS AS THE REGULATOR
YOU MUSTKNOW WHAT YOU LOOK AT
IT AND EXPECT TO SEE IN A
CURRICULUM SO I'M NOT SURE THAT
I UNDERSTAND WHY IT WOULD BE SO
TERRIBLY DIFFICULT TO SPELL
OUT. EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR IN A CURRICULUM IN A COMMON
CORE CURRICULUM WITH POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES THAT COULD BE IS
ON THE SHELF AND IF THE SCHOOL
WANTS TO ACCEPTED. THEY
ACCEPTED AND SAY GOOD WE'RE
GOING TO GO WITH THAT SO YOU
CAN MOVE ON TO SOMETHING ELSE
BEYOND CURRICULUM POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES I ASSUME IT'S BRICK
AND MORTAR FACILITIES SINCE
IT'S A CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AND
ALL THE OTHER ISSUES THAT YOU
LOOK AT. MISTRETTA MAKE IT
SIMPLE AND I THINK OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS SAYING WE'RE
SAYING THE SAME THING SHE CALLS
OF THE STATE CURRICULUM BUT IF
THE STATE CURRICULUM A CHOICE
SOMEONE CAN OPT OUT AND DO
SOMETHING MORE. MORE- A
SPECIFIC IF THEY WANT TO IF
THEY WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
DELAY THAT THAT'S GOING TO-
BECAUSE IN TERMS OF THE
APPROVAL PROCESS I JUST AS THE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT IT I DON'T
WANT TO BELABOR IT TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
SEE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AGGRESSOR CONDEMNS ALL. I GET
INTO THIS. THEN DIRECTLY-
LANDED YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COOPERATION AS YOU KNOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN IN A NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS AT THE STAFF
LEVEL AND AT THE DIRECT MEMBER
LEVEL ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES
AND- I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
SERVING IN THIS CAPACITY WHEN
WE TOOK A LOOK AT THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS FOUR YEARS AGO I
KNOW THAT YOU WERE APPOINTED
SUBSEQUENTLY AFTER- AND- JUST
SPEAKING VERY PLAINLY ENGLISH
THE BOARD WAS A DISASTER. AND
IN COMPARISON TO THE OTHER
ENTITIES THAT WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AS
YOU KNOW THIS PROCESS IS OUR
OBLIGATION ON THE OVERSIGHT. ON
WHAT WORKS WELL AND WHAT
DOESN'T WORK WELL SO AGAIN I
COMMEND YOU FOR BEING OPEN
TRANSPARENT. AND SPEAKING
DIRECTLY TO THESE ISSUES.
HAVING SAID THAT LET ME JUST
GET STRAIGHT RIGHT INTO THIS
THEN TOO BUT- I. AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM AN OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND THEY SAID IT AND MUCH MORE
ELEGANT WAYS BUT- I SEE AND
IT'S- COMPLETE GROSS
NEGLIGENCE. AND THE CAPACITY TO
HANDLE THIS ISSUE OF SCHOOL
APPROVALS. WHAT I HAVE BEFORE
ME IS A LIST OF FIFTY FOUR
PENDING SCHOOLS ON REFERRALS.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT EVEN IF
I'M LOOKING AT THE STATUS THE
WAITING LIST. THE DATE OF
RECEIPT OF THE FIRST
APPLICATION WAS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THIS IS
STILL PENDING APPROVAL THIS IS
FOUR YEARS IN THE MAKING. IS
THAT IS THAT ACCURATE TO SAY
THAT MY LOOKING AT THE CORRECT
DATA. THAT THE STATUS FOR
EXAMPLE OF. THE FIRST IN LINE
IS STILL THE DATE OF RECEIPT IS
STILL BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH WOULD BRING
THIS TO FOR YEARS. THIS
YAMAGUCHI. YES SIR I'M AFRAID
YOU'RE CORRECT OKAY SO. THE
NATIONAL ACCREDITORS HAVE A
LIMITATION APPROVAL OF THREE
YEARS. SO WE ARE BEYOND THAT OF
BUT THE NATIONAL STANDARDS ARE.
AND EVEN ACCORDING TO YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE ROAD AND IN IN
YOUR BACKGROUND PAPER IT'S UP
TO THREE YEARS RIGHT YES THEY
ESTIMATED TIME FOR APPROVAL IS.
NO MORE THAN THREE YEARS IS
THAT IS THAT THIS THE CEILING.
I'M SORRY. COULD YOU REPEAT
THAT PLEASE HOW LONG DOES IT
TAKE WHAT IS THE MAXIMUM TIME.
FOR SCHOOL TO BE APPROVED.
INCOME REGULAR IS NOT A MAXIMUM
TIME THERE'S NOT A MAXIMUM TIME
OKAY- AND WHAT IT WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS A REASONABLE TIME. FOR
APPROVAL. I WOULD THINK TWO
YEARS TWO YEARS OKAY THANK YOU
SO THE NATIONAL CREDITORS HAVE
A LIMITATION OF THREE YEARS
MAXIMUM. YOU FEEL YOU'VE JUST
ADDRESSED IN THIS COMMITTEE
THAT HE BELIEVES TWO YEARS IS
THAT A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR SCHOOL TO BE APPROVED.
AND YET. THE SCHOOL THAT IS
NUMBER ONE IN LINE IS STILL
BEEN WAITING FOR YEARS THAT IS
THAT ACCURATE. YEAH I'M AFRAID
YOU'RE CORRECT OKAY. AND SO DO
YOU HEARD THAT IT IS OUR
OBLIGATION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ZIP. FOCUS ON THE
PIPELINE DEVELOPMENT OF HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS THE FIRST SCHOOL
THAT WE SEE LISTED IS IMPERIAL
COUNTY. THE SECOND CHOOL IS AN
ORANGE COUNTY THE THIRD IN
POMONA. THE FOURTH EN EL CENTRO
THE FIFTH INTERLOCK THE SIX IN
PLACERVILLE THE SEVENTH AND
RANCHO CORDOVA THE EIGHTH IN
RIVERSIDE. SO BUT I WANT TO
UNDERSTAND IS WHERE IS THE
SENSE OF URGENCY TO ADDRESS
THAT THIS TEXTBOOK EXAMPLE OF
RED TAPE WHERE DOES THE BUCK
STOPS IN ADDRESSING THIS GROSS
INCOMPETENCE DOES IT LIE WITH
YOU OR DOES IT LIE WITH THE
BOARD. WELL. I WOULD HAVE TO
SAY RICE PRESS WITH ME SIR.
THANK YOU ELAINE AND AGAIN I
DERIVE NO PLEASURE IN HAVING
THE DIRECT CONVERSATION AND YOU
KNOW I HAVE SURE THIS DIRECTLY
ON THE PHONE AS WELL AND- IN
ANTICIPATION OF THIS HEARING.
AND THEY CANNOT BILL IF THEY
TELL ME LIES WITH YOU. AND
WE'RE ASLEEP AT THE WHEEL. HOW
DO WE RECTIFY THE SITUATION AND
HOW WE ENSURE THAT THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY WHAT IS YOUR
RECOMMENDATION ON
ACCOUNTABILITY IF WE'VE ALREADY
OUTLINED THIS GROSS NEGLIGENCE.
OF THESE APPROVAL PROCESS THAT
DOESN'T EVEN MEET YOUR TIMELINE
AND YOU'RE TAKING OWNERSHIP OF
IT. WHAT TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
DO YOU RECOMMEND THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY. TAKE INTO
ACTION. YOUR NUMBERS STEPS IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS- ALL WHICH NEED
TO BE KIND OF COORDINATEDSOME
TO ACT UPON. THIS NEGLIGENCE IF
YOU WILL- A LOT OF FACTORS LED
TO IT- THERE'S THAT'S NOT AN
EXCUSE FOR THE WAY A LOT OF
FACTORS LED TO THIS AND LET
CERTAINLY TO- THE MUSHROOMING
OF THAT OVER THE PAST I WOULD
THINK. AM I WOULD SAY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS- CERTAINLY STAFFING
REVENUE. THE ABILITY TO WORK-
AND CERTAINLY LAST YEAR- WHEN
THE NEC'S DROPPED EVERYTHING TO
WORK WITH THE EXISTING SCHOOLS.
AND SPENT PROBABLY MORE THAN
85% OF THEIR TIME. MAKING
CERTAIN THAT THE EXISTING
STUDENTS THE EXISTING PROGRAMS.
COULD TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITIES CONTINUE ON AND IN
THE IN THE PAST- BUT- TO MOVE
FORWARD- I THINK WE OUTLINED A
NUMBER OF. OF POSSIBLE PATHS IN
THAT MANNER AND- IDEAS THAT
COULD BE ENACTED SOME OF WHICH
COULD BE ENACTED RIGHT AWAY-
WITH BOARD APPROVAL. SEVERAL
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE I THINK
SOME STATUTORY AUTHORITY SOME
OF WHICH WOULD REQUIRE SOME
RULE MAKING. AN ESPECIALLY ALL
OF WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THIS
BOARD TO BE MORE FISCALLY
SOUND- I THINK OUR REVENUE
STREAM AS AS I'VE SAID A NUMBER
OF TIMES. NEEDS TO BE
STABILIZED- I THINK IN TERMS OF
THE SCHOOL PROGRAM THREE. I
THINK THIS IS A CONTRIBUTING
CAUSE TO THE MUSHROOMING OF OUR
LIST BECAUSE- BLUNTLY BRN
REQUIRES. A PROGRAM TO. THE
FULL APPROVAL FEET WITH THIS
LETTER OF INTENT AND- THEY-DON'T REALLY HAVE AN
APPRECIABLE WAITING LIST
BECAUSE THE PROGRAMS WHO ARE
READY TO PROPOSE A PROGRAM. OR
FAIRLY WELL SITUATED AND HAVE
THE READY MISS TO MOVE FORWARD-
IN BECAUSE THEY'VE MADE ALREADY
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT. VERY
MUCH INCENTIVIZE TO MOVE
FORWARD AS QUICKLY AS THEY CAN
AND CERTAINLY TO BE AS
RESPONSIVE TO THEIR NEC'S- IS A
NUMBER OF FACTORS AS I SAID I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT- WE
WOULD. ABSOLUTELY WELCOME.
DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE STAFF-
AND MOVING FORWARD HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THIS I THINK
THERE'S- THERE'S SOME OTHER
UNDERLYING FACTORS AS WELL. AND
BUT WE ARE CERTAINLY. READY AND
ABSOLUTELY AMENABLE TO
RECOMMENDATIONS WE- I THINK-
THE COMMITTEE WILL RECALL THAT
OUR OUR BOARD UNDERWENT A
FAIRLY. DETAILED EXTENSIVE
ANALYSIS FIRST WOULD BE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM- WITH THE
POINTED UP ENFORCEMENT MONITOR
WHO SUBMITTED- SOME FIFTY ODD
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD
THEM IMPLEMENTED- THEN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN WE
WORK WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS. IT
WAS THEN CALLED OFF THE CHANGE
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT IS NOW
ORGANIZATIONAL IMPROVEMENT
OFFICE- WE HAD INTENDED TELL
THE EDUCATION PROGRAMS GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AS WELL IN
TWENTY TWENTY- BUT-
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
DO SO I DO. HAVE A START DATE
OF JUNE OF THIS YEAR TO START
THAT PROCESS AS WELL SO I THINK
THERE'S- THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS GOING ON. ALTOGETHER
THAT NEED TO BE COORDINATED AND-
BUT AS I SAID THERE'S CERTAINLY.
ON OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
TO THINK THROUGH NEW OPTIONS-
I'M CERTAINLY OPEN TO ANY OTHER
SUGGESTION I KNOW DOCTOR
MOUNTAIN WOULD BE AS WELL- AND
THE BOARD NEEDS TO I THINK
REALLY STEP BACK AND ASSESS
THE- THE WAY WE DO THIS
BUSINESS- TO DATE- WE HAVE.
THIS LIST HAS BEEN MONITORED-
ON ONGOING BASIS AND BUT REALLY
THAT THE MONITORING IS YOUR
NUMBER THIRTY SOMETHING DO YOU
WANT TO STAY ON THE LIST. IT
HASN'T BEEN. VERY THE DETAILED
THERE HASN'T BEEN LIKE A
TRIAGING OR PRIORITIZATION
THINK THERE'S- ONE OPPORTUNITY
THAT I THINK WE DISCUSSED WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IS. WHAT IF
WE HAD THE APPROVAL PROCESS
MORE FRONT LOADED AND THEN THE
INITIAL LETTER INTENT WAS
FOLLOWED BY A MUCH MORE
DETAILED APPLICATION. UP FRONT
WITH NO IDENTIFICATION OF
RESOURCES- ASSESSMENT OF
REGIONAL NEED- L. VARIETY OF
FACTORS THAT WOULD ENABLE US TO
STATE RANK YEAH CATIONS THE
PROPOSAL SO THAT. WE ARE THEY
ARE MOST NEEDED AND CERTAINLY-
MOST TURN KEY IF YOU WILL-
WOULD HAVE AN ACCELERATED
PROCESS. LIKE I SAID THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ALL OF OPTIONS AND
MEMBER OF- OF CONCEPTS AND I'M
CERTAIN THEIR IDEAS THAT WE
HAVEN'T THOUGHT OF- BUT AGAIN-
I KNOW. IT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE- OF LANE
YOU YOU. AGAIN AS I SUBMIT I
WAS HERE THREE YEARS AGO WHEN
WE DIDN'T THIS SENSE AT LAST
TIME- AND THEN SUBSEQUENT
ANDERSON YOUR APPOINTED BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE BOARD
WAS IN SUCH A TERRIBLE
POSITION. THAT THE BOARD'S
AUTHORITY TO HIRE YOU WAS GIVEN
TO THE OUT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THAT OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY I APPRECIATE
YOUR RECOGNITION OF THAT. BUT
THE BOARD AND YOURSELF YOU KNEW
THAT THIS SUNSET HEARING WAS
GOING TO OCCUR. AND YOU KNEW
THAT THIS WAS A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM. PRIOR TO THE JUST US
HAVING THIS PROCESS AND THAT'S
BY THE WAY WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT IMPERATIVE THAT WE
HAVE THE SENSE THAT. HEARINGS
FOR A NUMBER OF THE BOARDS AND
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
BUT YOU KNEW THIS WAS AN ISSUE
AND YOU DIDN'T YOU KNOW THAT
THE BOARD BRING IT TO OUR
ATTENTION. UNTIL JUST JUST NOW
TO TALK ABOUT. HERE THE
PROBLEMS. AND IT'S DUE TO LACK
OF STAFFING SO THEREFORE WE
NEED MORE BUDGET OR THE OR WE
STATUTORILY NEED SOME CHANGES.
SO BRING IT TO OUR ATTENTION.
BUT NOW IT'S YOU'RE REACTING.
TO THE SUNSET HEARING TO WHICH
NOW WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
TO CALL THIS OUT. WHY WOULD YOU
NOT BE IN A PROACTIVE POSITION
TO SAY IT'S MY OBLIGATION AS
EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE. FOCUSED ON THE
PIPELINE. AND MAKING. GETTING
GETTING RID OF THE RED TAPE SO
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN SUPPORT.
OUR STUDENT POPULATION AND
ENSURING THAT YOU HAVE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND
FRONTLINE. WELL WHY DID YOU NOT
BRING THAT TO OUR ATTENTION
EARLIER AND NOW BUYS IT JUST
NOW THAT WE'RE- HAVING A PUBLIC
DIALOGUE ON THIS. THAT'S A VERY
FAIR. ASSESSMENT SIR- I THINK
TO THE BOARD'S DEFENSE- THERE
WERE A VAST NUMBER OF FACTORS.
THAT WERE. BONFIRE M. SO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN WERE
SPENT PRIORITIZING AND- THE
REORGANIZATION AND THE
REVITALIZATION OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT LICENSING PROGRAMS.
AND I THINK AND I WOULD HAVE TO
GO BACK AND LOOK FOR CERTAIN. I
THINK OF IT AT THAT POINT. THAT
WAITING LIST WAS MUCH MORE
MANAGEABLE I THINK IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN. SOMEWHERE IN THE TWO
DOZEN AREA. AND WE FOUGHT OF
COURSE THAT STAFFING WOULD BUT
NOT BEING ABLE TO TURN THAT
CUSTOMER- I WAS INCORRECT-
AGAIN WE THOUGHT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE ARE FULLY STAFFED WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO TURN THAT
CORNER AND AGAIN I WAS
INCORRECT- SO I DON'T HAVE AN
EXCUSE I DON'T HAVE. A REASON
PER SE OF NOT FLAGGING THIS AS-
AS URGENT AS AN ISSUE AS AS I
SHOULD HAVE PERHAPS- BUT THE
BOARD'S PRIORITIES WERE TO.
ENSURE THAT. THE LICENSING
FUNCTIONS SOME WERE BROUGHT
INTO ORDER TO FEED FORTUNATE
FUNCTIONS WERE BROUGHT INTO
ORDER YEAH. THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT
FOR NOW. SO EVER ENTERED IN
HERE HE SAYS THAT YOU FAILED TO
IDENTIFY THAT THIS WOULD
INCREASE THE BACKLOG WOULD
INCREASE AND THAT YOU FAIL TO
TAKE. THE ACTION AS EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OFFICER TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF THIS BACK
WHILE. THAT WOULD BE FAIR SIR.
I'M LOOKING AT THE. PROPOSED OF
THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE INSIDE THE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE SUBMITTED
APPLICATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THAT
I'M LOOKING AT. THE SCHOOL IN
RANCHO CORDOVA IRWINDALE. OR LA
HABRA OR SALINAS OF COURSE WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE HARD TO
SERVE IN HARD TO REACH AREAS.
BUT THESE APPLICATIONS WERE
SUBMITTED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND- TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
EARLIER THIS YEAR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. SO WITH THE CURRENT
BACKLOG. IF WE JUST DO SOME
BASIC MATH. OF WHAT WHAT'S
THREE ASSESS WHAT'S YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF WERE TO ASK YOU
APPROXIMATELY HOW MANY SCHOOLS
DO YOU APPROVE A YEAR. BUT THE
ANSWER POTS WERE HOW MANY
SCHOOLS. CAN WE ASSUME THAT YOU
APPROVE EACH YEAR. I WOULD
THINK BETWEEN TWENTY AND THIRTY.
TWENTY AND THIRTY SCHOOLS A
YEAR. I WOULD THINK SO OKAY SO
IF I'M IF I IF OF SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION BACK IN. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. I'LL BE
ABLE TO BEAT THAT THAT TIMELINE
THAT USS ABOUT. THREE YEARS.
UNDER EXISTING STRUCTURE YES
PROBABLY THREE YEARS SO AS YOU
CAN SEE THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES TO THIS
AND IT'S OUR DESIRE ESPECIALLY
DURING GET RID COMING OUT OF A
CODEPENDENT MAKE THAT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE PIPELINE GETTING
FRONTLINE RESPONDERS OUT. IT'S
IT SHOULD BE INTERPRETED BY
NUMBER OF THE QUESTIONING FROM
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
THAT IS NOT A GOOD SIGN. IF YOU
LOOK AT A NUMBER OF THE OTHER
BOARDS AND BUREAUS THAT HAVE
COME BEFORE HE'S OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS. MANY OF THEM GO
SEAMLESS WITHOUT. MANY
QUESTIONS. BUT THE TEMPTATION
OF ALL OF THESE CHALLENGES AND
QUESTIONS TO LEAVE YOU TO. THE
CONCLUSION THAT THERE IS A LACK
OF CONFIDENCE IN YOUR ABILITY
TO EFFECTIVELY DO YOUR JOB AS
WELL AS THE BOARD. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THEN THAT WE WILL DO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO ON THE
POLICY REVOCATIONS HELP EMPOWER
YOU BECAUSE WHAT I'M HEARING
YOU SAY. IS THAT YOU DO NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY NOR ARE YOU
SET UP FOR SUCCESS AND SO BY
DEFAULT YOUR SET UP TO FAIL. IF
THAT IS THE CASE THEN I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU WORK WITH US IN
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY TO HELP
IMPLEMENT POLICIES SO THAT YOU
STATUTORILY CAN BE SET UP FOR
SUCCESS. BECAUSE IN MY HEART OF
HEARTS I KNOW FOR A FACT THAT
YOU WANT TO DO THE BEST THING
YOU'RE DOING. AS MUCH AS YOU
CAN. BUT IT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT YOU ARE NOT- AND SO.
THERE'S A DISCONNECT SO LET US
TRY TO CONTINUE TO TAKE LOW
LEVEL OF SERIOUSNESS IN THE
SENSE OF URGENCY ON THESE
ISSUES AND HELPING TO INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE IN US AND NOT JUST
BY CONVERSATION BUT INACTION A
BECAUSE WE ARE BEHOLDEN TO THAT
OF THE TAX PAYER AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND WHEN WE HEAR
FROM THE SCHOOLS ABOUT THESE
ATROCITIES IT'S OUR JOB THAN TO
HELP FOCUS AND ADDRESSING THE
RED TAPE. AND NOT SEEING THE
GROSS NEGLIGENCE THAT WE SEE IN
STATE GOVERNMENT SO I WELCOME
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH YOU AND BEFORE WE
GET ANY TO ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
ANY FINAL. THOUGHTS OR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
SIXTEEN. THEN WE'LL JUST GO TO
THE OPERATOR OPERATOR WOULD YOU
CUT ME OPEN UP THE LINE. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT- IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN TESTIFIED ON THE
BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX. TWO
THREE SEVEN PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON. THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBERS.
WHEN YOU'RE MY NUMBER IS CALLED
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. FOR THE
RECORD ONCE AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT FOR TODAY'S CALL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM A
LINE EIGHTY SIX. NINE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY I'M IN LINE FOR THE C. A.
M. P. C. SCORE NEED TO CALL
BACK LATER. NINE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KOBE
PRESIDING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS- WE REPRESENT
ROUGHLY SIX THOUSAND STATE
LICENSED- PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS AND APPROXIMATELY-
TWELVE THOUSAND SIX AFTER
TECHNICIANS THROUGH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS THE
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATION- I
WANT TO JUST. BRIEFLY STATE
THAT- I THINK- EXECUTIVE
OFFICER- AND A TREMENDOUS JOB
CONSIDERING WHAT SHE HAS TO
WORK WITH AT THE TIME- WORKING
DURING THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC
AND TRYING TO TRIAGE- SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS- AND PRIORITIZE
THEM IT IS NO SMALL TASK AND I
JUST WANTED TO THANK HER FOR
HER EFFORTS- SECONDLY. I THINK
PART OF THE REASON WHY-
EXECUTIVE OFFICER YAMAGUCHI IS
HAVING- SUCH STRUGGLES IS THAT
THERE IS NO FEE FOR THE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS FOR THE
FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS- THIS
PROHIBITS HER FROM HIRING. MORE
STAFF TO DIRECTLY- TRIAGE THIS
BACKLOG OF SCHOOLS WAITING
ACCREDITATION PROCESS. AND
ADDITIONALLY YOU KNOW V. BOARD
IS SEEKING REGULATORY AUTHORITY
RIGHT NOW TO INCREASE THE FEES
ON LICENSE FEES THAT HE IS
SUBSIDIZING THE COST OF AND
THEIR INSTITUTIONS TO GET
ACCREDITED. SO NOT ONLY ARE-
STUDENTS PAYING FOR TUITION
THEY ARE THEN GOING THROUGH THE
LICENSING PROCESS AND THEN PAY
A FEE FOR LICENSING. SO IT JUST
STRIKES ME AS- COMPLETELY
UNFAIR THAT THE LICENSEES ARE
SUBSIDIZING THE COST OF FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS I THINK
SOMETHING COULD BE ESTABLISHED
IN WHICH- COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COULD HAVE A WAIVER AND THEN
NONPROFITS GET OUT A SLIDING
FEE SCALE- AND THEN OR PROFIT
SET UP A BILLABLE HOUR TYPE
SYSTEM ON THE COST THIS LITTLE
OUR OF THE BOARD IF YOU HIRE
MORE- NURSING- COORDINATORS
NURSING EDUCATION COORDINATORS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CHALLENGES HAS PASSED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN LAW
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
HAVE A COMMENT FOR THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
NINE SEVEN. SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. EARLY BIRTHDAY AND TCM.
AND I WAS WONDERING AND THAT.
YOU KNOW WHEN THEY PLAN TO MAKE
IT A STATE WIDE PROGRAM ABOUT
EVERY CITY AND COUNTY AND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THREE CRITERION MASSAGE
THERAPIST HERE TO GET SB AND
ANOTHER CONNECTION THAT'S FOR
THE NEXT TO HEARING THIS IS
CURRENTLY ON SEX OF BORDER
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. OKAY
WELL THEY PUT AN NINE SEVEN SO.
OKAY ALREADY GOTTEN KILEY. IT
WILL BUT MAKE A NOTE TO THE
EDITOR JUST LAST THE NEXT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU DO HAVE A COMMENT FOR THE
BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE ONE
FOR THE COMING.
ONE SECOND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GET THAT
THE LINE NUMBERS. NINE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. THIS IS
BURKE FOUND WHEN THE- CO GUARD
ACADEMY WE AT SIX CAMPUSES IN
CALIFORNIA- BEFORE I BEGIN I
JUST WANT TO SAM CREATION OF
ALL THE COMMENTS FROM THE
CHAIRS WERE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- YEAH VERY WELL
ADDRESS ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CONCERNS ABOUT APPLICATION
APPROVAL PROCESS- WE DID HAVE
ANOTHER- ITEM THAT WE REALLY
THINK NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AND- AND THAT IS THE LACK OF
TOOLS AVAILABLE. TO SCHOOLS TO
IMPROVE THEIR THAT STUDENT AND
COLLECTS RESULTS AND OUTCOMES-
ONE OF THE MODELS THAT WE'VE
SEEN- IS THROUGH THE B. ARE AND
WHERE THEY'RE GETTING AND
GIVING US QUARTERLY RESULTS ON
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC STUDENTS.
OUTCOMES ON THE INFLUX AND ADDS
A LITTLE SO WHEN WE SAY THREE
YEARS AGO WE HAD VERY LITTLE
INSIGHT- INTO OUR VOCATIONAL
NURSING STUDENTS. IN PARTICULAR
WE USED TO HAVE- INFORMATION ON
COHORTS AND- FROM WHICH CO CORK
WAS TAKING AND THEIR SUCCESS
RATE ON THE INFLUX AND THAT HAS
ALSO SINCE BEEN TAKEN AWAY ALL
WE GET IS INFORMATION ON OUR
PASS RATES FOR- THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT TOOK IT THAT
COULD BE SOMEONE FROM. TWO
YEARS AGO TAKING A COULD BE AN
COLLECTION COULD BE SOEONE
FROM TWO MONTHS AGO TAKING A
CLASS M. YOU KNOW IN ADDITION
WE HAVE. NO WAY TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE SPECIFIC DISCIPLINE OR
SPECIALTY WITHIN THE PROGRAM SO
THAT WE CAN ACT ON THAT AND SEE
IF WE HAVE A COHORT A RELATED
ISSUE A CLINICAL RELATED ISSUE-
OR MAYBE A TEACHING OR
CURRICULUM. THE ISSUE AND
TACTICS SO- WE WOULD REALLY-
PROMOTE HAVING AND USING THE B.
R. AND MODEL SINCE WE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT AS WELL AND
TO APPLY THAT TO THE- OF
LOCATIONS NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS- AND
CLICKS RESULTS. INFORMATION AND
DATA. THANK YOU MUCH. ONE ONE
L. A. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO. THANK YOU NAME'S ROBERT
JOHN ON THE DIRECTOR TO THE CAL
SOCIAL OF PRIVATE PROCESSORS. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBERS
FOR THEIR INSIGHTFUL COMMENTS
DAY AND ANALYSIS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN LACKING
IN THE LEGISLATURE REVIEW
PROCESS OVER THE YEARS AND- I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE- THE
AMOUNTS OF- BRAINPOWER- THAT-
WHICH HASN'T SHOWN ON THIS
ISSUE TODAY. WE WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT ONE THING THAT MAYBE
WE CAN WORK WITH THE BOARD- THE-
TESTING FOR IT. WAS GOING TO
PUT REGULATIONS YET ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO DEALING WITH. THAT
KIND OF LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
THAT NCC'S HAD TO GOVERN THE
SCHOOLS WILL BE FOUNDER THE
PANDEMIC IS THAT MANY NEC'S ARE
SEXUALLY TRYING TO OPERATE THE
SCHOOLS THROUGH LETTERS- AND
SENDING REQUESTS FOR VOLUMES OF
DATA. ASKING FOR GUARANTEES OF
CLINICAL SITES WELL IN ADVANCE
OVER A YEAR IN ADVANCE FOR
SCHOOLS ESSENTIALLY GUARANTEE
THE CLINICAL SITES WILL BE
THERE- THIS DOESN'T WORK IT'S
REALLY NOT POSSIBLE TO DO-
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WE
ACTUALLY FILED AN ASSOCIATION
ANY. UNDERGROUND BRAG COMPLAINT
WITH THE OFFICE MINISTRY OF LAW
ON THE DDOT DIRECTOR BACKED OFF
ON THAT BUT STILL KIND OF
FLOATING AROUND- REGULATIONS
MAKE SURE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT EITHER STATUTE OR
REGULATION MAY OUTLINED THE
SPECIFIC JOBS AND DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND
AUTHORITIES. FOR THE BOARD
STAFF SO THE SCHOOLS UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS RESPECTED THEM AND.
BASICALLY HOW THEY CAN RESPOND
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ENCINO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE GALLERY- HERE
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM. AGAIN
TO- DR MOUNTAIN AND ALSO TO-
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER LAYING
I'M GUCCI YOUR SUCCESS IS OUR
SUCCESS WE LOOK FOR TO THE
CONTINUE PARTNERSHIP AND HAVING
ADDITIONAL DIALOGUE MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL AGAIN WILL BE ASKING
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE COUNCIL
TO LIMIT THEIR OPENING REMARKS
TO NO MORE THAN THREE MINUTES
WITHIN TAKE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND OPEN UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR THE
MOTT MASSAGE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL JOINING US
TODAY R. D. BOARD PRESIDENT IS
THE BOARD PRESIDENT THE BOARD
VICE CHAIR THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER SPECIAL COUNSEL GENERAL
COUNSEL DIRECTOR OF EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS DIVISION. MANAGING
DIRECTOR AND DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. WITH THAT SAID
WE'LL TURN IT OVER TO THE
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNSEL FOR
YOUR OPENING REMARKS. JEFF. I
DID IT IS IT WORKING NOW YEAH
IF YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN LOW
CHAIRMAN ROTH IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR JEFF
FOREMAN AND ON SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
AFTER RETIRING FROM DE ANZA
COLLEGE AS A FULL TIME
INSTRUCTOR FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS
I WAS APPOINTED. BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO REPRESENT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON THE C. A.
M. P. C. BOARD. D. ENDS ARE I
FOUNDED AND DIRECTED THE
MASSAGE THERAPY PROGRAM THE
FIRST 80 DEGREES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE FIRST
JACKSON'S OFFICE APPROVED
CERTIFICATES IT MASSAGE
THERAPY. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN I WAS ELECTED AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD AND- I'D
LIKE TO SAY I'M EXTREMELY PROUD
OF HOW THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ALLOWED CA M. G. C. TO ELEVATE
THE MASSAGE THERAPY PROFESSION
OUT OF THE SHOWER CHANNELS. TO
BEING RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE
MOST REQUESTED ALTERNATIVE CARE
MODALITIES. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH ME TODAY AS
ARE THE IS THAT YOU. AND IN THE
END F TIME. I'D LIKE TO.
ALMOST NOT YOU ALLOWS. MAKES
MORE LASTING REMARKS. I DON'T
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
LOW CHAIRMAN OFF AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ALMOST NO CANAL I'M THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL. MY INVOLVEMENT WITH
MASSAGE THERAPY GOES BACK TO MY
MILITARY DAYS WHEN I WAS AN
ISRAELI PARATROOPER. AND I WAS
INJURED IN A COUNTERTERRORIST
RAIDS IN LEBANON. PART OF MY
RECOVERY INCLUDED WHAT WE NOW
ALL KNOW AS MASSAGE THERAPY. MY
LIFE WAS CHANGED BY LEARNING
FIRSTHAND WHAT THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH. HAS
CONCLUDED THAT MASSAGE CAN BE
CRITICAL TO THE RELIEF OF
PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL PAIN.
MASSAGE THERAPY IS LISTED IN
CALIFORNIA LAW AS A HEALTHCARE
MODALITY AND IT IS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE LIVES OF MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS SEEKING PAIN
RELIEF MANAGING STRESS AND
BRINGING HEALTH AND WELLNESS TO
THEIR LIVES. THIS IS MY THIRD
SUNSET REVIEW HEARING. THE
PREVIOUS HEARINGS WERE HELPFUL
IN REFINING OUR MISSION TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC BY VETTING
IS CERTIFIED MASSAGE
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE ALSO WORKED WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE TO ADD THE
RESPONSIBILITY OFF APPROVING
MASSAGE PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE
LEGAL STANDARDS FOR TRAINING
AND CURRICULUM. IN MY BRIEF
OPENING STATEMENT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT SEEM TO SEE HAS
FOCUSED ON WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN WAYS THAT INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY. USTRANSPARENCY
INCLUDES HEARINGS TO BAGLEY
KEENE OPEN MEETING ACT. THE
BOARD THAT IS DIVERSE AND
WILLING TO BRING DIFFERENT
VIEWS FOR THE DISCUSSION. BRING
AN OPEN BOOK TO EXPENDITURES
AND PROVIDING CLARITY IN
OPERATIONS. ALTHOUGH IT IS
SOMETIMES UNAPPRECIATED WE ARE
TRANSPARENT REGARDING
EDUCATIONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE INHERENT.
ACCOUNTABILITY THESE
LEGISLATURE DEMANDED WHEN THEY
ESTABLISH A FIVE OH ONE SEE
THREE THEN BRING SENSIBILITY TO
THE SAFE AND LEGAL PRACTICE OF
MISSILES. IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT WHILE THE OVERSIGHT OF
MASSAGE THERAPY CAN BE COMPLEX.
INDIVIDUAL AND IS CONSTANT SEEM
TO SEE DOES NOT TAKE ANY MONEY
FROM THE STATE. YOU WILL HEAR
TODAY INROADS WE HAVE MADE
THROUGH EDUCATIONAL EFFORTS THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION WORKING
WAS ARE CERTIFICATE HOLDERS
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS. AND
IT THE PROTECT THE MOST
AFFORDABLE GOVERNING ENTITIES
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND DJS WHO
BRING. INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY
TO THE MASSAGE INDUSTRY.
ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT MAKE US
UNIVERSALLY LOT BUT SEEM TO SEE
CERTIFICATE OR CERTIFICATES
REFLECT FIVE HUNDRED HOURS OF
TRAINING FROM VERY GOOD
SCHOOLS. IT SEEMS TO SEE
SIGNIFICANT SEND A MESSAGE TO
CONSUMERS AND EMPLOYERS THAT
THE MASSAGE PROFESSIONAL HE'S
QUALIFIED TO PROVIDE SAFE AND
HEALTHY MASSAGE. CVC IS NO
STRANGER TO THE UNDERBELLY
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED FOR TOO
LONG WITH MASAK. I EXPECT WE
WILL TALK TO DATE OF%
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND HOW WE
HAVE CONSISTENTLY OUTPERFORMED
TARGETS SINCE OUR LAST HEARING.
I ALSO EXPECT WE WILL DISCUSS
HOME SEEING TO SEE RESPONDS
WITH SIX THIRTY. WHEN A
DISCIPLINARY ACTION IS
NECESSARY AT A LOW COST THE
GOVERNMENT BOARDS CANNOT. WE DO
THIS WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
PROVIDING FULL AND FAIR DUE
PROCESS. OUR STRUCTURE ALLOWS
HIM TO SEE TO BE A RECOGNIZED
LEADER IN THE BATTLE AGAINST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
EXPLOITATION. CNBC HAS REMAINED
OPEN AND ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
PROVIDING CRITICAL UPDATES
DURING THE DIFFICULT YEAR. THAT
HAS BEEN SHADOWED BY THE SPEND
THEM. IN THE PAST TWELVE MONTHS
WE'VE RESPONDED TO THOUSANDS OF
QUESTIONS FROM THOSE WE SERVE
AND DOES ONE WHO NEEDS
CLARIFICATION ON THE ROLE OF
MASSAGE THERAPY DURING HIS
HEALTH CRISIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEY WE'VE EXCEEDED OUR
THREE MINUTES FOR THE OPENING
REMARKS FROM THE COUNCIL I AM
NOW TURNED THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME SO AGAIN
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOLLOWED BY
PUBLIC COMMENT SO GOING TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. OF WILL BEGIN WITH
SENATOR LEYVA. THIS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW RANGE FROM
THE SUN. SORRY FULL DIFFERENT
FROM THE SENATE A GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE IS
THE OF THE FINAL POINT OF YOUR
TALKING POINTS REGARDING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AND IN THE FALL
THE MASSAGE PARLOR BUSINESS IS
THE SECOND MOST COMMON CONTEXT
FOR SEX TRAFFICKING AFTER
ESCORT SERVICES. MY QUESTION IS
HOW DOES THE CURRENT REGULATION
OF MASSAGE THERAPY PROFESSION
CONTRIBUTE TO STATEWIDE EFFORTS
TO COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING. I
WOULD BE HORRIFIED TO KNOW THAT
I WAS IN THE PROFESSIONS WHERE
OF MY PROFESSION WAS THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND FOR ME
PERSONALLY I WOULD MAKE THAT A
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY TO PUT A
STOP TO THAT. SO JUST CURIOUS
WHAT YOU ARE DOING TO STOP THAT
AND HOW WE CAN PUT A STOP TO
THAT. I'M WORRIED TO US K. C.
M. D. C. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES I
WOULD I SEEM TO SEE DIRECTOR OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO ADDRESS
THIS QUESTION. BEVERLY MAY
HELLO THIS IS AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION E'VE BEEN HONORED BY
IT DOESN'T MOVES THAT ARE SENT
LETTERS THANK YOU SEE EMPTY
SEATS WERE SUPPORT ON THESE
ISSUES IN A RECENT REPORT
PUBLISHED BY THE SOUTH BAY
COALITION AND SHE TRAFFIC INTO
THE CHAMPIONS SANTA CLARA ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT ILLICIT
MASSAGE INDUSTRY CURRENTLY
OPERATES WITH LITTLE TO NO
REPERCUSSIONS IS BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY. IT
WOULD NOT SERVE THE INTERESTS
OF THE STATE TO HAVE THE
MASSAGE INDUSTRY REGULATED BY
ASSISTING ON. CMCC NEED MODEL
THAT IN OUR- WITH THE JURISTIC
PROVIDED BY STATE LAW WELL WITH
THE SENSIBILITY TO OPERATE AS A
NONPROFIT. THE BAY AREA ANTI
TRAFFICKING COALITION HAS
REDUCED ITS C. A. R. T. C.'S
WORK QUOTE AS AN EFFECTIVE
NONPROFIT IS AN INTEGRAL PART
OF MAKING THE VERY SIMPLE
MASSAGE INDUSTRY SAFE PLACE
OWNERS THEIR ARTISTS AND
CLIENTS. JOHN MANNING WAS THE
FIRST UNION TRAFFICKING OFFICE
IN SAN JOSE AND IS CURRENTLY
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
COORDINATOR SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
YOU DON'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE ALL COMMENTS TODAY.
JOHN IS A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERT ON THE SUBJECT. HE SAID
C. A. M. P. C. ONLY EXPERT
MACHINE TRAFFICKING. AND HAS
ENCOURAGED US TO EXPLAIN
LEADERSHIP IN THIS ARENA. THE
CURRENT ROUND REGULATION OF THE
MASSAGE THERAPY PROFESSION
MASSAGE PROGRAMS IS WELL
RECOGNIZE. BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AS WELL AS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ORGANIZATIONS IT GETS RIGHT
INTO THE PARADIGM OF PREVENTION
PROTECTION PROSECUTION AND%
PARTNERSHIPS. THAT MAKE UP AN
INTERNATIONAL FRAMEWORK USED BY
THE UNITED STATES AND THE WORLD
TO COMBAT TRAFFIC. CMT'S PLACE
YOU NEED ROLE. CHAU SEN BURKE
EVERY TV TO SEARCH ALL. THE
EDUCATE THEM ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE ENTERPRISE PROVIDING
CONTACTS TO THOSE WHO MAY
INDEED IT TELLS. CMT C. HAS AND
CONTINUES TO TRAIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ON SCENE
TRAFFICKING AND OTHER. CRIMES
SUCH STREET. CMCC HASH AND
EARNS ARCTIS SOUND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OPERATIONS IN THE
STATE INCLUDING ARMS ACROSS
CLARA SAN MATTEO VENTURA
COUNTY'S. WORKING CLOSELY WITH
VICTIM SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
DIRECTLY SERVE THIS POPULATION
CMT C. SUPPORTS OUTREACH TO
HELP PROTECT POTENTIAL VICTIMS
UNDERSTAND THEIR OPTIONS
INCLUDING THE POSSIBILITY OF
FALLING BEHIND AND SALAS. SOUTH
STE. CMT'S IS DIRECTLY. I'LL BE
IMPLEMENTED BEST PRACTICES-
CENTER CONSCIOUS THESE REASONS.
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS
COALITIONS COLLABORATIVES IN
TASK FORCES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WELCOME PARTNERSHIPS WITH
CMT C. IN FACT SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AND LOCAL MASSAGE
REGULATIONS AND MOST BURDENS.
TO THE GENERAL OPERATORS HAVE
IN THE PAST NINETY NINE EASILY
PROMOTED BISON TRAFFICKING
ORGANIZATIONS THEMSELVES THESE
REGIONAL AND NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS COME TO
APPRECIATE PARTNERING WITH CA
NTC EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE
AND BEST PRACTICES THAT DO NOT
HARM THE PROFESSIONALS SUCH.
MISS MISS VERY MICE BUT MY PLUG
FOR DRUG PREP SO WHICH TO GET
TO THE QUESTION FROM SENATOR
LEYVA SPECIFICALLY I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU HAVE A STANDARD
RESPONSE WITH RESPECT TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT I THINK CENTER
CENTER LEYVA PRESSURE CAN
REFINE YOUR QUESTION. YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW YES I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE TO BECAUSE YOUR SPOTS
RESPONSE MAKES IT SOUND LIKE
EVERYTHING IS WONDERFUL AND
ROSIE AND IT'S NOT YOUR IN YOUR
YOUR- F THE MATC. AND MASSAGE
PARLORS ARE NUMBER TWO IN SEX
TRAFFICKING IF ONE PERSON IS
SEX TRAFFICKED YOU'RE FAILING
SO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT NO
ONE IS BEING SEX TRAFFICKED IN
THE MASSAGE THERAPY INDUSTRY I
HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU DON'T
WANT STATE REGULATION. AND YOU
NEED THAT FLEXIBILITY BUT IF
THERE IS ONE PERSON AD THERE
ARE PROBABLY A LOT MORE THAN
ONE PERSON BEING SEX TRAFFICKED
THEN MAYBE STATE REGULATION IS
NEEDED SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING SPECIFICALLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY MASSAGE
PARLOR. IS NOT TRAFFICKING. IN
HUMANS FOR SEX. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO START BY TYLER THAT SUCH
PARLOR IS A LITTLE BIT OF AN
OUTDATED TERM. SITTARD IT'S
DISLIKED BY THE MASSAGE
PROFESSION. BUT- THIS IS A-
NATIONWIDE PROBLEM AND IT'S
EXIST IN STATES WITH THE MOST
STRINGENT REGULATIONS. ON THE
WAY THAT- SLOT ONE WAY THAT
FLORIDA DEALS WITH IT IS BY. BY
REQUIRING PROOF OF CITIZENSHIP
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT'S MASSAGE
ESTABLISHMENT THE COMPLICIT
DOWN IF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE PROOF
OF THE RIGHT TO WORK. IN NEW
YORK IT'S A CLASS C. FELONY TO
BE WORKING. WITH AND WITHOUT A
STATE LICENSE IN THE STATE
WHICH MEANS OR WAS DOWN C. M.
D. C. HAS DONE A WONDERFUL JOB
WITH. THE WITH THE CONVENTION.
HARD BY. WHY OF NO LONGER
RECOGNIZE OVER HOW SCHOOLS THAT
WERE FRAUDULENTLY SELLING ART
ALSO FIND TRANSCRIPTS. AND I
THINK THIS IS HAS BEEN PASSED.
YOU TAPPED AS WELL AS TRAINING
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ORDERED
FORSMAN I WANT TO LOOK. THE
SEATTLE C. M. A. THREE HAVE ANY
KIND OF STATISTICS TO HAVE ANY
IDEA OF ALL OF THE MASSAGE
THERAPY. PLACES OF BUSINESS I'M
TRYING TO BE MORE APPROPRIATE-
ANY IDEA HOW MANY ARE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HOW
MANY YEARLY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
HUMAN BEINGS TRAFFICKED IN SEX.
BOB SENATOR- I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE JUST TO
FRAME- FRAME DAVE- DAY GENERAL
INFORMATION IT WAS- THE
LEGISLATION THAT. RAPTURED ARE
DEREGULATION SUCH A WAY THAT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT CONTROL
ESTABLISHMENT SEEING BECAUSE HE
DOES NOT REGULATE
ESTABLISHMENTS WE VETERANS
CERTIFIED THE INDIVIDUAL
THERAPIST AND WE HADN'T A CLUE
OUR SCHOOLS- DAY ESTABLISHMENTS
HE'S UNDER THE CONTROL OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SO MAYBE WE NEED
FOR LOCAL CONTROL AND MORE
STRINGENT RULES AND LAWS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE
THIS ISN'T HAPPENING AT ANY
ESTABLISHMENTS. SEEM D. C. HAVE
ALWAYS SUPPORTED LOCAL CONTROL
WHEN IT COME TO THE WAY CITIES
AND COUNTIES- OUR REGULATING
BUSINESSES. JUST TO KEEP THINGS
IN PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE A VERY
ROBUST I REPRESENTATION ON CMT
C. BOARD FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE HAVE AN
APPOINTEE OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES WITH THEIR
FIVE CHILDREN SEEM TO SEE A
PLENTY OF BAY COUNTIES- SO WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY- WAS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THEM AND WE FULLY SUPPORT-
CITIES AND COUNTIES CONTROLLING
THEIR- THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
OKAY AND HOW DO YOU HOW WOULD
YOU FEEL ABOUT MORE STATE
REGULATION. SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
THE I I'M SORRY BUT I'M JUST
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS I
DON'T THINK THAT ANYONE SHOULD
BE TRAFFICKED AND USED FOR SEX
AND WE KNOW THAT IT HAPPENS TO
WOMEN AND YOUNG WOMEN. AND IF
YOU'RE IN A BUSINESS WHERE THIS
IS HAPPENING HOW DO WE PUT A
STOP TO THAT I UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
MASSAGE THERAPY YES THEY CAN BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL AND
BENEFICIAL TO PEOPLE BUT IF
THERE ARE NEFARIOUS PEOPLE WHO
ARE USING THIS FOR OTHER
PURPOSES. THEN HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
IF LOCALLY THE ARE THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE NOT TIGHT
ENOUGH THEN MAYBE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING AT THE STATE LEVEL SO
THAT THAT WAY THIS JUST DOES
NOT HAPPEN THIS THIS PRACTICE
DOES NOT HAPPEN THERE ARE BAD
ACTORS IN ANY. IN THE INDUSTRY
BUT IN THIS THESE BAD ACTORS
RUIN PEOPLE'S LIVES. IF YOU. WE
ARE ALWAYS OPEN TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND TO
DISCUSS ANY IDEAS- THAT CAN
ADDRESS THIS- TERRIBLE PROBLEM
I SEEM TO SEE WHAT BUT SEEM TO
SEE DOCTOR READY ARE PRODUCED
TREMENDOUS RESULTS IN REDUCING-
THE SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE VERY OPEN TO ANY
IDEAS THE ANYBODY THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE ONE
OTHER QUESTION MISTER CHAIR FOR
ME AND I'M SORRY I SOUND LIKE
I'M BEING VERY A NEGATIVE TODAY
BUT I JUST HAD A QUESTION-
MISTER CEO ABOUT YOUR
COMPENSATION THREE HUNDRED
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS
SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY I
KNOW THAT YOU DON'T TAKE ANY
STATE MONEY- BUT YOU I BELIEVE
YOUR COMPENSATION IS
COMPLETELY. PAID FOR THROUGH
THE FEES THAT PEOPLE PAY
THROUGH CA MTP AND I'M JUST
WONDERING IF I'M JUST WONDERING
WHY YOU NEED THAT MUCH MONEY TO
DO YOUR JOB. ANYTHING THAT HAS
TO DO IS THAT A CEO
COMPENSATION IS BEING GOVERNED
BY THE BOARD. AND I'M GONNA ASK
THIS SEEM TO SEE VICE CHAIR DR
ON BATES TO ADDRESS THIS. WHILE
WORKING FOR THEM TO KEEP I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS I USED TO
I'M IN MY OLD JOB FOR RAN FOR
OFFICE I HAD A BOARD AS WELL.
AND I THINK IT'S A VERY EASY TO
OUT TO SAY THAT IT IS GOVERNED
BY THE BOARD. I WAS THE ONE WHO
WHO'S IN WHAT Y. BOARD WANTED
TO COMPENSATE ME I'M SURE IT
WAS ALWAYS FAIR AND IN LINE
WITH WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN THE
REST OF THE INDUSTRY. SO I
THINK IT'S EASY TO BLAME IT ON
THE BOARD BUT IF THE BOARD
WANTS TO GIVE YOU AN INCREASE.
HE WAS A AS YOU CAN SAY NO I
THINK THAT IT'S I DON'T NEED
THIS MONEY TO PAY. THIS MUCH
MONEY TO DO MY JOB. FIRST OF
ALL MISTER IN MY HOME. OKAY
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS RIGHT
BATES- I'M VICE CHAIR OF THE
BE- CAMTEK BOARD AND I
REPRESENT THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ON THE BOARD
I HAVE OVER FIFTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE ALL RIGHT DIDN'T
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE IN A
SENSE THE CITY MANAGER IN
VARIOUS CITIES AND AS A LOCALLY
ELECTED OFFICIAL AND MAYOR OF
MY PHD HAPPENS TO BE R. IN
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION WITH A
SPECIALTY IN FINANCE. M. I WAS
THE BOARD MEMBER THAT REQUESTED
THE COMPENSATION STUDY FOR THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SO THAT WE
COULD ESTABLISH A SALARY THAT
WAS FAIR AND EQUITABLE THEN NO
BOARD CHAIRMAN DID MYSELF MARC
DIXON CONSTITUTED A
COMPENSATION COMMITTEE WE
INTERVIEWED DEL FOR NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED FIRMS TO DO THE
COMPENSATION STUDY. CBS WAS
SELECTED BECAUSE OF THEIR
BACKGROUND OF DOING
COMPENSATION STUDIES FOR
NONPROFITS AND VERY COMPLEX
ORGANIZATIONS C. BIZ IS A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
CONSULTING AND ACCOUNTING FIRM
FOUR THOUSAND EMPLOYEES THAT
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE-
NINETY THOUSAND CLIENTS A
HUNDRED OFF THIS IS IN THE
UNITED STATES AND IS TRADED ON
THE NEW YORK STOCK STAGE AS YOU
CAN UNDERSTANDA VERY CAPABLE
OF BURKE AS MENTIONED CAMP TAKE
GIVES A VERY COMPLEX
ORGANIZATION THAT CA ALMOST
DEAL EFFECTIVELY. WITH D. A.
SHARE POLICE CHIEFS THE LETTER
FACIALS AT ALL LEVELS AND THEIR
STAFF ASKED CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS MASSAGE SCHOOLS WITH
THE EXTRA TICKET HOLDERS
THEMSELVES AND MANY OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AROUND THE COUNTRY TO
NAME A FEW IF THE JOB IS TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN AND COMPENSATION SHE
NEEDS TO BE. SET WHICH IS FAIR
TO CAMP CHECK AND IT'S. A
DIFFICULT WILDER'S- BUT ALSO. I
ARE RIGHT. IN THE APPROACH.
OVER PAY. BUT THE- HAS BE FAIR
TO ME. OF WELLQUALIFIED- C. E.
O. OF FOR A LITTLE MORE DETAILS
SO WE DON'T NECESSARILY AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION WAS
FULL OKAY STOP ARE MOST- BUT
SENATOR I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT WE HEAR FROM YEAH.
A LOT TODD SHE'S A MANAGER
DIRECTOR OF CPOS WHO LET THIS
STUDY'S GOT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE HAS WRITTEN A
BOOK CALLED REASONABLE COMP.
STATION A SPECIALIST APPROACH
AND I THINK TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE MORE DETAILS. AS TO HOW
IT WAS DEVELOPED AND THEN HELD
THE BOARD CONSIDERED OF FAIR
COMPENSATION FOR THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SO WITH THAT MAYBE-
WELL- ALMOST COULD ADDRESS IT
THANK YOU I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THE POINT BUT I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT IN MY NOTES- THE-
MEDIAN SALARY FOR AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR IN THIS POSITION IS A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. THAT'S WHAT I
MADE LAST YEAR AS A AS A STATE
SENATOR MY SALARY WAS A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
I WOULD ARGUE THAT I REPRESENT
A MILLION PEOPLE I HAVE TO
MAINTAIN A RESIDENCE THE TWO
PARTS OF THE STATE I WORK
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AS WELL. BUT
AND I THINK THAT I'M A VERY
EFFECTIVE SENATOR AND I THINK I
REPRESENT THE STATE OF MY
CONSTITUENT VERY WELL AND I'M
NOT PAID 300-606-4000 DOLLARS A
YEAR SO I'M JUST MAKING THE
POINT. THAT MANY PEOPLE WORKS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN MANY PEOPLE
DEAL WITH ALL THE ENTITIES THAT
YOU SPOKE ABOUT. THAT AND ARE
PAID ENCOMPASSES. THE THING I'M-
HIS SALARY COULD BE HIT SO
CAREER. AS SOME OF THAT MONEY
COULD BE USED TO MAKE SURE THAT
NO ONE IS SEX TRAFFIC. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
REPRESENTATIVE I JUST A FALL
THE QUESTION BY SEN ROTH FROM
MYSELF AND THEN BY SOME MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM. HE WILL BE. OKAY
YEAH I DID JUST ON THAT IT
BECAUSE OF IT WAS BROUGHT THAT
UP ON ON THE ON THE
CONVERSATION I'D BE CURIOUS TO
GET GET FEEDBACK ESPECIALLY
FROM THE COUNCIL ON BUT THIS IS
FOR COLLEAGUES THIS ON PAGE
TWENTY THREE. OF THE- OF THE-
THE BACKGROUND PAPER. AT WITH
RESPECT TO COMPENSATION ON
COMPATIBLES. ARE YOU REFERENCED
EARLIER ABOUT- DOING AN
ANALYSIS A COMPARATIVE ANALYSIS
WITH OTHER. ENTITIES OF UP FOR
COMPENSATION- BUT THIS IS A
REGULATORY ENTITY THE OTHER.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU USE FOR
COMPATIBLES OUR TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- FOR
EXAMPLE- WITH LICENSEES THAT
ARE MAKING EASILY OVER SIX
FIGURES. L.A. AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WITH FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND AS TO WHY. THESE ARE
NOT BE INTERPRETED AS APPLES
AND ORANGES. MAYBE TO THE BOARD
VICE CHAIR. OKAY. I'M SORRY
BABY OKAY AND MAKE YOURSELF
TIMELY. WHERE ANYONE IS WITH IT
WOULD HAVE WHAT A BOARD MEMBER
WILL WISH TO RESPOND. ANY OF
THE BOARD MEMBERS. WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO REPEAT THE QUESTION
THAT HELPFUL. WE'LL SENATE.
RATA WITH WITH CIBA'S I WITH
THE CONSULTANT THAT HELPED WORK
ON THE ANALYSIS STE I'D BE
HAPPY TO RESPOND- ABOUT THE
PROTOTYPES LIKE SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS MAY BE HAVING
DIFFICULTY- SPLIT WITH THE WEB
ALL. WOULD THAT BE HELPFUL. YES
AGAIN THE QUESTION IS IF YOU
YOU I HEARD EARLIER FROM THE
BOARD MEMBER. WITH YOUR ON THE
QUESTION OF. ARTICULATION AND
THE VALUE OF THE COMPENSATION
AND ART WE HEARD EARLIER. THAT
THERE WAS A STUDY A COMPARATIVE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE. BUT
COULD IT I DIDN'T COVER THAT
IT'S APPLES AND ORANGES BECAUSE
SOME OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
I AS I UNDERSTAND IT AND
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG. BUT
WE'RE YOU TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
NOT A REGULATORY ENTITY LIKE
THAT MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL
AND USING COMPARISON TO THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
OR THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. OF WHICH AGAIN FOR
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ITS
LICENSEES ARE EASILY MAKE SIX
FIGURES PLUS AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE DEALING
WITH EXECUTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH. A MILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES AND FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES. WITH A WITH
THE OBLIGATION TO ITS
SHAREHOLDERS NOT ITS TAXPAYERS
AND RUNNER AND- LICENSEES CAN
YOU HELP US UNDERSTAND AS TO
WHY THESE TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
WERE USED FOR COMPARATIVE
ANALYSIS. SURE SO I MAY ARE
PROBABLY AN INCH OR MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS BECAUSE- I'M FROM A BIG
PICTURE PERSPECTIVE. UP THEY
ARE A BIBLE C. THREE
ORGANIZATION. AND THAT'S PART
OF THAT THERE ARE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS FROM THE IRS IS
BEING PART OF A BIBLE ONE TWO
THREE. RELATED TO EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION- CAN BE FOUND IN
THE IRC. FORTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT
THE FIELD INTERMEDIATE
SANCTIONS- AND IS LESS THE
SPECIFIC TYPES OF DATA THAT
SHOULD BE USED. WHEN COMPARING
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION IT
SPECIFICALLY LAST OTHER BIBLE
ONE SEE THREE- OR OTHER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AS
APPROPRIATE COMPARISONS AND SO
IN ORDER TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH. FRANKLY IRS REQUIREMENTS
WE WILL LOOK AT THOSE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS BUT- THAT'S THE
COMPLIANCE WITH IDEA TO LET LET
ME ASK. ANSWER FROM A MORE.
MARK BASED- KA. ACROSS IN THAT
IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION YOU TEND TO SEE
THE STRONGEST CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE SIZE OF AN
ORGANIZATION AND CEO OR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COMPENSATION
SO YOU'D EXPECT THE CEO OF A
TEN BILLION COMPANY TO EARN
MORE THAN THE CEO OF A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR COMPANY ALL ELSE
BEING EQUAL. AND SO AS WE
IDENTIFIED THE CURES FOR
COMPARISON OUR FOCUS WAS ON
LOOKING AT OTHER NONPROFITS
WE'RE LOOKING AT BECAUSE
WESTERN A CALIFORNIA BASED AS
WE COULD FROM A GEOGRAPHIC
PURPOSES REALLY THE FOCUS WAS
ON BOTH SIDES OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS BY LOOKING AT THE
SIZE OF STAFF. TO SAY HEY THIS
IS A LARGE ORGANIZATION ARE
VERY ORGAN. HOW DO FIND THE
MOST COMPARABLE- ORGANIZATIONS
IN TERMS OF SIZE OR COMPARISON.
BUT THAT WAS JUST ONE PIECE OF
THE ANALYSIS THAT YOUR
NONPROFIT ALSO WE LOOKED AT
SPECIFIC NONPROFIT PEERS. WE
ALSO LOOKED AT PUBLISHED SALARY
SURVEY DATA SO AS A FIRM WE
SPEND UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR ON
COMPENSATION SALARY SURVEY DATA
AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO LOOK LIKE
INDUSTRY GEOGRAPHY AND SIZE OF
ORGANIZATION I'M FROM PUBLISHED
SALARY SURVEYS AS WELL. FINALLY
IT AND CERTAINLY I CAN HELP
WITH THAT I'VE BEEN TO MORE
DETAIL- THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL-
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT OUT. APPLES
APPLES COMPARISONS I'M SO I SAW
REFERENCE THE HUNDRED SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR BASED HEY- I'M
NOT. HAVE NOT DONE A DEEP DIVE
ON THE BENEFITS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE POSITIONS-
BUT- WITHIN THIS ORGANIZATION.
LAURIE AS WELL AS TOTAL CASH
COMPENSATION BENEFITS TOTAL
COMPENSATION IT'S ALL ON THE
SAME THERE ARE NO BENEFITS NO
RETIREMENT. THANKS SO IT'S
IMPORTANT WE UNDERSTAND. THE
TOTAL VALUE OF COMPENSATION AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING OUT. IN APPLE
INC BASED FAKE COMPARED TO AN
ORANGE IN TOTAL COMPENSATION.
SO WITH THAT AGAIN HAPPY TO
DIVE INTO ANY SPECIFICS- AND
AS- I WOULD BE REQUESTED. THANK
YOU I KNOW THIS IS A BECAUSE A
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY- BY THE
BEGINNING THAT THIS IS A
REGULATORY AS WELL WHICH IS THE
CASE WHERE IN WHICH YEARS
BEFORE US RIGHT NOW. THE
AVERAGE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
COMPENSATION IS A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN AND IF WE LOOK AT THAT
FOR EXAMPLE OF LICENSEES OR
CERTAIN THOSE WHO ARE CERTIFIED
IF THE AVERAGES. THIRTY DOLLARS
AN HOUR. THE AVERAGE A
CERTIFIED THERAPIST WHAT WHAT
THE AVERAGE COMPENSATION THIRTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR. WAS THAT ON
THE HIGH END. ANYONE. AGAIN
THESE ARE NOT LICENCES
CURRENTLY THE THESE ARE THOSE
WHO ARE CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST. WHAT IS THE AVERAGE
COMPENSATION. FOR A CERTIFIED
MASSAGE THERAPIST. I'M NOT SURE
YOU'RE ASKING A QUESTION TO ASK
IT ANYONE WHO'S TO TELL ANYONE.
ANY VERY HIGH I DON'T HAVE THAT
DATA BUT THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
DOESN'T DOESN'T SOUND
OUTRAGEOUS AS THE BIRDS OBSERVE
DISCUSSION OKAY SO PURPOSE OF
DISCUSSION. IF AVERAGE
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST IS
MAKING THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
AND THEY EXECUTIVE OFFICER AS
AN 8% AUTOMATIC INCREASE. 8%
AUTOMATIC INCREASE IN WHICH
THAT WAS GRANTED THIS YEAR.
NEVER MIND OUT OF THE COPA
PANDEMIC IN THOSE WHO MIGHT NOT
BE ABLE TO DO IN PERSON.
SERVICES BUT AUTOMATIC 8%
INCREASE. BUT THE BENEFITS
TOTALING THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IS
IT APPROPRIATE. FOR AN
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. TO BE
COMPENSATED AT THREE HUNDRED
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT
8% AUTOMATIC INCREASE WHEN THE
AVERAGE CERTIFIED THERAPIST IS
MAKING THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR.
I'M SORRY I GUESS COUPLE THINGS
JUST TO CLARIFY IT SO I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE AUTOMATIC 8%
INCREASE I CAN'T TALK MUCH
ABOUT- I'M NOT ALONE BUT YOU'D
SAID THAT. YOUR BENEFITS WAS
THREE HUNDRED AND SOME ODD
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF
THE VALUE OF BENEFITS AT XEROX
I GREW UP TOTAL COMPENSATION.
WELL ACT. OF BUT MAYBE JUST
APPROPRIATE YOU. EDWARD BUT
AGAIN I THINK THE BIGGER EVERY
NOTICING SOMETHING THAT'S
COMPLETELY TONE DEAF THE BOARD
INCREASED FEES THIS YEAR FOR
CERTIFICATION TO ITS CERTIFIED
SERVICE YOU JUST INCREASED FEES
THE FEE INCREASE. AND DURING
THE COVERED PANDEMIC YOU HAVE
CERTIFIED THERAPISTS WERE
UNABLE TO WORK AND YET THE CEO
COMPENSATION HAS THE AUTOMATIC
INCREASE OF 8% EVERY YEAR. AND
IT'S OUTSTANDING THAT ITSELF
CURRENTLY AT THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT'S THAT THAT'S WHERE I
THINK WE'RE GETTING AN AND WE
MAY BE HIGHLIGHTING AGAIN ON
PAGE TWENTY THREE OF THE- ISSUE
RAISED A NUMBER THREE STAFF
COMPENSATION. THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE. AND IT JUST
APPEARS TO ME THAT. WE CAN'T
CHERRY PICK. WELL WE'RE
REGULATORY ENTITY BUT THEN
WE'RE ALSO NONPROFIT SO WHAT
WOULD YOU CAN CHERRY PICK THE
BENEFITS OF BEING NONPROFIT.
AND THEN CHERRY PICK THE
REGULATORY SIDE AND THEY'RE NOT
GETTING ANY OF THE OTHER TYPE
OF. CRITICAL. TYPE OF SCRUTINY
ACCOUNTABILITY- BUT THOSE ARE
JUST MY INITIAL COMMENTS HAD A
SENSE OF A PRINT PRODUCT. YOUR
YES HELLO JUST BEFORE YOUR
INFORMATION I SEEM TO SEE BOARD
DID NOT INCREASE ANY FEES THIS
YEAR- IN THE ELEVEN YEARS
SIMPLY SEE EXIST HE'S WERE
INCREASED ONLY ONE TIME AND I
BELIEVE THAT WAS IN LINE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DOES THAT
MEAN CAME OUT OF THE
INFORMATION IN FRONT OF ME- A
IN WHAT THE BORDER. AND HE'S ON
STOP. IN THE PAST TWELVE MONTHS
CNBC WAVE COMPLETELY ALL OF ITS
LATE FEES- TO ALLOW
SECURITYHOLDERS MORE TIME TO
RECERTIFY IF THEY NEED MORE
TIME AND WAVE COMPLETELY- ALL
OF THOSE FEES. ARE ALSO- YEAH I
WOULD LIKE TO THE BORDER DRESS
THAT I WOULD JUST ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE WITH THE CENTER A
CENTER LIVE YEAH DEAD LAST YEAR
WITHOUT BEING ASKED I INITIATED
A DEFERRAL ON MY COMPENSATION
TO THE TUNE OF ALMOST SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS- BECAUSE WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED OFFICE FINANCES
A AND- SO I INITIATED THESE-
DEFERRAL LAST YEAR- AND IN
REGARD TO THE INCREASED THERE
IS NO AUTOMATIC INCREASE I'M
NOT SURE WHERE THAT INFORMATION
CAME FROM. THE BOARD IS IN
COMPLETE CONTROL ARM OFF ANY
INCREASE- DEBT THIS YEAR OKAY.
THANK YOU OF JUST FIVE TO
CLARIFY THAN I AYES IN THE BACK
PAPER A VERBATIM A YEAR IT SAID
THAT THERE WAS NO INCREASE AT
APPRECIATE THAT'S A BABY COULD
CLARIFY. I HAVE HEE ON PAGE
ELEVEN BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASE IN OPERATING
EXPENSES CAN TECH INCREASED ITS
FEES WITH ITS INITIAL
APPLICATION AND RECERTIFICATION
FEES RAISED FROM A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. TO TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IS
THAT INACCURATE IN YOUR- IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. I DON'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION FROM IT COULD
BE EITHER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND
WHEN IT COMES TO FEES- LET'S
JUST KEEP IN MIND THAT. THE
LEGISLATOR SET UP OF FEET OF
WATER SEEM TO SEE WAS INITIALLY
CREATED THERE WAS NO FEE LIMITS
SEEM TO SEE BOARD WAS ABLE TO
CHARGE- ANY FEE THAT- IT IT'S
ALL FAIR. THE BOARD IS VERY
SENSITIVE TO THE ISSUE OF
IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING FEES LOCK
DOWN THAT IS WHY THEY CHARGE
ONLY A HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS. A
INDOOR NO INCREASING FEES FOR
YEARS THERE'S ONLY ONE TIME
INCREASING FEAR GUESS. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. FROM ONE
FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED. AND SO
THE BOARD IS VERY SENSITIVE
THIS ISSUE. EVEN THOUGH IN A
SUBSEQUENT SUNSET REVIEW THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE CEILING
OF THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
THE BOARD COULD HAVE CHARGED
MORE STEEL THE- I'VE DECIDED TO
KEEP IT FEES BELOW THE
THRESHOLD THAT- THE LEGISLATURE.
SO WE ALWAYS DO WHATEVER WE CAN
TO FEET TO KEEP FEES AS LOW AS
POSSIBLE OKAY JUST FOR JUST A
PUBLIC RECORD TO YOU PREVIOUSLY
STATED THAT THERE WAS NO FEE
INCREASE IN THE PAST. ARE
WITHIN THE LAST PAST ELEVEN
YEARS BUT WE JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT I'M SAID THEY SAID THERE
WAS ONE TIME INCREASE OKAY. AT
ONE TIME WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN. I BELIEVE THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY SO THE- OF WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS THAT THERE IS A
THERE HAS BEEN A FEE INCREASE-
RECOGNIZING AS YOU HAVE SEEN IN
A NUMBER OF THESE. OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS THAT. THE COMMITTEE IS
SENSITIVE TO FEE INCREASES AND
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE
CLARIFIED THAT AS WELL BUT BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
THERE'S A QUESTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I WANT TO GET
BACK TO THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ISSUE FOR A MOMENT. ACCORDING
TO POLARIS DOT ORG A NONPROFIT
THAT TRACKS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ACROSS THE WORLD. THERE ARE. AN
ESTIMATED OVER NINE THOUSAND
MASSAGE. PARLORS I UNDERSTAND
PARLOR ISN'T THE TERM YOU GUYS
PREFER SAW CALL THEM MASSAGE
FACILITIES. OVER NINE THOUSAND
MASSAGE FACILITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES INVOLVED IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING- CALIFORNIA HAS
MORE OF THOSE FACILITIES THAN
ANY OTHER STATE- BOTHIN
ABSOLUTE TERMS AND PER CAPITA.
ACCORDING AGAIN TO POLARIS DOT.
WORK. IT OCCURS TO ME- I
UNDERSTAND YOUR ARGUMENT THAT
YOU MADE IN RESPONSE TO A
PREVIOUS QUESTION. THAT YOU
DON'T WANT STATE OVERSIGHT THAT
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY WANT
STATE LICENSURE- I'M
SYMPATHETIC TO THAT AS A
STARTING POINT- THE ARGUMENT
COULD BE SUMMARIZED THAT YOU
MADE AS IF IT AIN'T BROKE DON'T
FIX IT. BUT I THINK THE MESSAGE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO CONVEY TO
YOU TODAY IS THAT. WHEN IT
COMES TO. REGULATING AND
IDENTIFYING AND STOPPING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHICH WITHIN THE
MASSAGE. IT IS BROKE. WHAT YOU
ARE DOING NOW IS INSUFFICIENT.
AND YOU NEED TO FIX IT OR I
BELIEVE THE STATE WILL BE
FIXING IT FOR YOU. SO I FIRST
WANT TO CONVEY THAT MESSAGE AND
PERHAPS MORE PLAINSPOKEN TERMS.
A WHEN YOU HAVE OVER NINE
THOUSAND NATIONWIDE A GREAT
MAJORITY THOSE ARE A GOOD
PERCENTAGE OF THAT IN
CALIFORNIA- YOU HAVE A PROBLEM.
IN YOUR INDUSTRY PERIOD. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS THE FASTEST
GROWING FROM A ENTERPRISE IN
THE WORLD TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
ESTIMATED WORLDWIDE IT'S
HAPPENING CALIFORNIA MORE THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE AND WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT NOW. WE NEED
YOUR HELP DOING THAT. IF YOU
HAD A CANNABIS ASSOCIATION AND
YOU HAD A PROBLEM OF THAT
MAGNITUDE WITH BLACK MARKET
MARIJUANA YOU WOULD HAVE A
PROBLEM IF YOU WERE RUNNING A
CHAIN OF PHARMACIES AND YOU HAD
A PROBLEM WITH FENNEL WALKING
OUT THE BACK DOOR YOU WOULD
HAVE A PROBLEM IF YOU WERE. THE
BAR ASSOCIATION YOU'RE
REGULATING LAW FIRMS. AND A
HUGE PERCENTAGE YOUR LAW FIRMS
WERE STEALING THEIR CLIENTS
TRUST MONEY YOU WOULD HAVE A
PROBLEM. SO I HOPE WE'VE
CONVEYED TO ACCURATELY AND-
FORCEFULLY THAT IT IS BROKE ANY
DEFECTS. SO MY SPECIFIC
QUESTION AND I'D APPRECIATE A
SPECIFIC ANSWER FROM PREFERABLY
THE CEO. WHAT MECHANISMS DOES
YOUR ORGANIZATION HAVE IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW TODAY. TO IDENTIFY
MASSAGE FACILITIES THAT MAY BE
PARTICIPATING IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ONE TWO TO REPORT
THAT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS SO INVESTIGATIONS CAN
BE CONDUCTED AND THREE TO
REDRESS IF IT IF IT DOES TURN
OUT THAT IN FACT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS OCCURRING AND
ONE OF THE FACILITIES THAT'S
PART OF YOUR ORGANIZATION. I
APPRECIATE VERY SPECIFIC AND
DETAILED ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- SO FIRST ARM
AGAIN THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL DOES NOT TO
REGULATE MASSAGE ESTABLISHMENTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ONLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTHAS
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
ESTABLISHMENTS IN DANGER IT'S
JURISDICTION- WE DO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH FIVE
HUNDRED POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND
SHERIFF'S- BUT SEEM TO SEIZE.
OUR MANDATE IS TO VET AND
CERTIFIED THE INDIVIDUAL
THERAPIST. IN TWO- APPROVED
SPECIFIC MASSAGE PROGRAM. THAT
WAY WE CAN HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIGHT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN GEORGIA
RESTRICTION. THE MAIN ONE OF
THE MAIN TOOL HAS TO DO IS
TRAINING THEM. ON THE ISSUE.
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATION.
BUT PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS WE'VE DONE TO
ASSIST IS TO DEAL WITH DIPLOMA
MALES WHICH YOU MEANT
TRAFFICKERS USE IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN CERTIFICATIONS FROM
SCHOOLS THAT ACTIVELY SELL
DIPLOMA. SO AGAIN. YOUR MIND
EVERYBODY SEEM TO SEE IT DOES
NOT HAVE ANY JURISDICTION OVER
MASSAGE ESTABLISHMENTS IN THE
STATE HE SAYS SPECIFICALLY
UNDER JURISDICTIONS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ONLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SEMINAR CUNNINGHAM
SENATOR ROB. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AS YOU CAN TELL THAT
WE'VE GOT SOME CONCERNS HERE
THESE ARE SOME VERY SERIOUS
ISSUES I WANT TO START BY
SAYING FROM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
WITH THE RECENT EXCEPTIONS AND
SOME OF THEM SIGNIFICANT- I
THINK THE COUNCIL IS A- IS AN
EXAMPLE OF A FISSION SEE AN
EFFECTIVENESS- IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND REGULATION
SO TO SPEAK OF AN OCCUPATION IN
THE STATE. AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT LICENSING AND ENFORCEMENT
AND MANY OF THE VARIOUS ISSUES-
COST AND BUDGET FISCAL THERE WE
TALK ABOUT WHEN WE DO THE
SUNSET REVIEWS WITH BOARDS- IN
THE STATE OF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WHILE THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES IN THE WAY
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT OF KERR'S.
BETWEEN YOUR NONPROFIT FORM OF.
OF ORGANIZATION IN THE TYPICAL
TRADITIONAL- STATE BOARDS THERE
ARE OTHER WAYS TO DO THE
OVERSIGHT AND OTHER WAYS TO
ENSURE. THE PROTECTION OF
CONSUMERS AND- PROTECTION OF
THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING-
ASSERTIVE CERTIFICATES IN YOUR
CASE LICENSES THAN OTHERS- AND
THE COUNCIL SEEMS TO WORK WHEN
IT COMES TO THAT BUT- THERE ARE
A COUPLE AREAS ACTUALLY SOME
SIGNIFICANT AREAS WHERE I THINK
AND I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES. SOME
FURTHER ATTENTION NEEDS TO BE
DIRECTED IN THE FIRST. IS THE
ISSUE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING- I
WILL SAY HAVING LISTENED TO THE
CONVERSATION BOTH MY COLLEAGUE
IN THE SENATE IN MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY. IS THAT-
THE COUNCIL HAS DONE A LESS
THAN SATISFACTORY JOB IN EITHER
EXPLAINING ITS INTERFACE WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. OR IN
CONDUCTING INTERFACE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOUR JOB IS TO PROVIDE
VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION OF
THOSE MASSAGE THERAPIST TO
CHOOSE TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
IT- BUT THERE'S A LARGER ISSUE
HERE AND I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
SIMPLY SAY WE JUST SORT OF FIVE
A SIDE. THERAPISTS AND NOT DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE OF WHAT GOES ON
IN THE FACILITIES THAT YOU DO
NOT CERTIFY BUT WHERE YOU'RE
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST
WORK. AND SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
THE NEXT TIME WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. THERE IS A MORE
DETAILED EXPLANATION AND
SPECIFIC EXPLANATION OF HOW THE
COUNCIL IS WORKING WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. WITH
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND FRANKLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL ALL OF WHOM HAVE A MUCH
GREATER ROLE. IN SOME RESPECTS
THEN THE COUNCIL DOES IN
PUTTING A STOP TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT YOU CANNOT SAY
ALL WE DO IS CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPISTS AND LEAVE IT AT THAT
AND THE EXPLANATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO SOME VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS. ASKING A VARIETY
WAYS WAS PRETTY GENERAL AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED AND I WANT
MORE DETAIL AND I SUSPECT MY
COLLEAGUES TO OR- THERE MAY BE
A CHANGE IN THE WAY WE DEAL
WITH MASSAGE THERAPIST AS AN
OCCUPATION IN THE STATE. NOW
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES MAY OR MAY
NOT REALIZE IS. IF WE CREATE A
LICENSING SITUATION THAT'S NOT
GOING TO END HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IT STILL REQUIRES ACTIVITY BY
THE LICENSING AGENCY BY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S BY THE
COUNTY SURE SENT BY THE LOCAL
POLICE CHIEFS TO PUT A STOP TO
IT BUT I'D I'D EXPECT MORE
EXPLANATION AND I CERTAINLY
EXPECT THAT THE NEXT TIME WE
DEAL WITH THIS. OTHER SECOND
ISSUE THAT I THINK YOU NEED TO
GIVE SOME THOUGHT TO IS
INCREASED PARTICIPATION BY A
MASSAGE PROFESSIONALS AND BY
DISINTERESTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. ON YOUR BOARD I THINK
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL AND ALSO TO
PROVIDE FOR SPECIFIC TERMS AND
FOR A MORE DEFINITE APPOINTMENT
PROCESS FOR YOUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS BECAUSE I THINK THAT
MAY ADDRESS SOME OF THE- THE
COMPENSATION CONCERNS RAISED BY
MY COLLEAGUES. NOW THE FIGURE A
HUNDRED AND OF US AT A HUNDRED
AND SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS
CITED FOR A GOVERNMENT STATE
EMPLOYER RUNNING ONE OF THESE
BOARDS THAT IS REGULATED BY THE
DCA AND OF COURSE. AS YOUR
COMPENSATION. POINTED OUT THAT
DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT A
VERY VERY GENEROUS
PARTICIPATION. IN OUR OUR
CALPERS SYSTEM THAT PROBABLY
NEEDS TO BE. VALUED ADDED TO
THAT- BASED COMPENSATION AND IT
ALSO ILLUSTRATES PERHAPS HOW
WOEFULLY UNDERPAID SOME OF OUR
STATE EMPLOYEES. THE GOOD ONES
WERE WORKING VERY VERY HARD AT
THESE BOARDS- EARN. THESE THE
OTHER POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS I
BELIEVE HAVING REVIEWED THE
BACKGROUND MATERIAL. THAT YOU
NEED TO A MUCH MORE ROBUST
APPROVAL PROCESS- AND A MUCH
MORE ROBUST. SYSTEM WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH- WITH APPROVALS
AND DISCIPLINE. HAVING TO DO
WITH SCHOOLS FRANKLY HAVING
HEARING OFFICERS EMPLOYED BY
THE COUNCIL MAKING FINAL
DECISIONS WITHOUT. ANY APPEAL%
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY-
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME SO THIS IS
MY CAR THIS IS MY QUESTION AND
YOU'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO RESPOND
TO IT HOW CAN WE IMPROVE THIS
PROCESS TO ADD A BIT MORE DUE
PROCESS TO THE PROPER. RESPOND
YES SIR. WELL FIRST OF ALL
THERE IS AN APPEAL PROCESS SO-
THE BEFORE SCHOOL GET EITHER
DENIED OR AREN'T APPROVED THEY
RECEIVE IT WHAT IT'S CALLED THE
PROPOSED DENIAL- DOCUMENT THEY
GET TO REVIEW IT THEY CAN
REQUEST A HEARING THEY HAVE A
HEARING IN FRONT OF HEARING
OFFICERS AND IF THEY ARE DO NOT
AGREE WITH THAT- DECISION OF
THE HEARING OFFICER'S THEY DO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REQUEST AN
APPEAL. IN FRONT OF THE ENTIRE
BOARD. A SO WE DO HAVE ALL
THESE PROCESSES IN PLACE I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
REGARD TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT. I LOVE TO
SHARE WITH YOU WOULD THAT SEEM
TO SEE AS A STRATEGIC PARTNER
OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. WE WORK VERY VERY
CLOSELY WITH ALL THE POLICE
CHIEFS OF ALL THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS LITERALLY ON A
DAILY BASIS I WE'VE ENTIRE
STAFF FOR. MANY OF THEM A PAST
LAW ENFORCEMENT- OFFICIALS
THEMSELVES WE DROP WAS LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON THE DAILY BASIS
SO WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST
COMMUNICATION PROCESS BETWEEN-
SHERIFF'S- AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
GENERAL'S WORK FOR CLOSELY WITH
THE ACE. SO DR- SYSTEM IS
ALREADY IN PLACE IN. ADDITION
TO THAT WE PROVIDED TRAINING.
COOL MORE THAN THREE TO. UP
OFFICE AND- DA'S- SHERIFF
DEPUTIES ON THE ISSUE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND OTHER ILLICIT
ACTIVITY SO EVEN THOUGH WE DO
NOT REGULATED ESTABLISHMENTS.
WE ARE THERE TO SUPPORT THEM
WITH OUR EXPERTISE AND- AND- ON
A DAILY BASIS WELL THE NEXT
TIME WE GATHERED TOGETHER AT
THE RIVER I'D LIKE FOR YOU TO
SOMEBODY TO PROVIDE SOME MORE
SPECIFICS AS TO WHAT YOUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE. WITH
RESPECT TO THE ELIMINATION OF-
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING I'M SURE
YOU HAVE THEM SOMEWHERE IN THE
SYSTEM AND I'D LIKE TO HEAR
ABOUT THEM BUT LET ME GO BACK
TO THIS HEARING OFFICER
BUSINESS IF IT DOESN'T WORK FOR
ME TO HAVE. HEARING OFFICERS
EMPLOYED BY THE COUNCIL. MAKING
DETERMINATIONS THAT'S NOT DUE
PROCESS. THIS IS ALLISON
SIEGEL- I SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
OVERSEE THE ENTIRE PROCESS TO
ADDRESS THAT. YES GOOD MORNING
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS- SO
FIRST OF ALL HEARING OFFICERS
RECEIVED YOU SEE ARE EMPLOYED
BY CTC BUT THAT'S REALLY NO
DIFFERENT THAN ALE JAY'S LETTER
IMPLIED BY THE STATE THAT ARE
MAKING DECISIONS ON MATTERS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE CHALLENGING
STATE ACTION WOMAN. LET ME YOU
THAT'S NOT TOTALLY TRUE. THE
ALJS GENERALLY WORK FOR AN
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LIFE
BELIEVE IN THE STATE. THEY'RE
NOT WORKING FOR THE SPECIFIC
AGENCY THAT IS DEALING WITH
THE- DECISION MAKING PROCESS
AND REPORTING PRESUMABLY TO THE
AGENCY SECRETARY OR DEPARTMENT
HEAD SO I BELIEVE IF I
UNDERSTAND HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS
IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT THAN
THE SYSTEM THAT IS DESCRIBED IN
OUR BACKGROUND PAPER AND THAT
YOU OPERATE UNDER AS A
COUNSELOR MY NOT CORRECT. WELL
YOU'RE CORRECT IN THAT REGARD
BUT LET ME SAY THAT FIRST OF
ALL HEARING OFFICERS ARE NOT-
LIKE THEY DON'T REPORT THIS TO
THE CBO OVERSEAS THE ENTIRE. UP
PROGRAM THEY REPORT TO THE
STAFF ATTORNEYS AND THEY DEAL
THE STAFF ATTORNEYS ON A DAILY
BASIS. THE HEARING OFFICER'S
ARE ONLY USED ON AN AS NEEDED
BASIS WHAT THAT MEANS IS
HEARINGS ARE HELD ON THURSDAYS.
AND THE ONLY WORK A FEW HOURS A
WEEK IF THEY'RE WORKING THAT
WEEK THEY DO NOT ALL WORK EVERY
ALL HAVE OTHER POSITIONS AND
JOBS BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY
LIMITED POSITION. AND THE ONLY
THING THAT THEY DO IS THEY'RE
DEDICATED AS HEARING OFFICERS
THEY ARE NOT INVOLVED IN ANY
OTHER PART OF THE PROCESS. SO
WHAT IS THE RECOURSE IF THE
HEARING OFFICER ISSUES A
DECISION AND THE BOARD. THE
ENTITY TAKES THE APPEAL TO THE
BOARD AND THE BOARD RENDERS A
DECISION THAT'S DEEMED
UNSATISFACTORY IS AT THE END OF
THE PROCESS. SO AGAIN HEARING
OFFICERS IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SCHOOLS THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN
INDIVIDUALS SCHOOL FOR SCHOOL
SECURITY OFFICERS HERE THAT
MATTER. IF THE INDIVIDUAL DOES
NOT LIKE THE DECISION FROM THE
HEARING OFFICER'S THEY CAN
GOING TO KILL TO THE BOARD
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION TO THE BOARD. THE
BOARD CAN EITHER UPHOLD THE
DECISION OR SEND IT BACK- IF
THEY UPHOLD THE DECISION THEN
THE SCHOOLS CAN GO AHEAD AND
APPEAL TO SUPERIOR COURT THEY
BRING A PETITION FOR WRIT OF
MANDATE WITH SUPERIOR COURT
CHALLENGING THE ACTION OF
SEEING TO SEE. BUT IS WHAT'S
THE STANDARD ON HERE ELEMENT IF
YOU WANT BILLION THIS. WHAT'S
THE STANDARD ON. ON ON REVIEW
OF REVIEW AT THE WRIT OF
MANDATE STAGES THAT SUBSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE WHICH MEANS IF THE IF
YOU KNOW. IF THE BOARD HAS ANY
EVIDENCE ON WHICH REASONABLE
EVIDENCE ON WHICH TO BASE THE
DECISION. THE DECISION STANDS
OR IS IT A GOOD NOVEL REVIEW. I
THINK IT IS IT IS BASED ON
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE WHICH IS
NOT MUCH OF AN APPEAL AT ALL I
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THIS
BECAUSE- THE CHAIR HAS OTHER
BUSINESS TO. MOVE THROUGH AND
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A LOT OF DUE PROCESS.
AND I AND I'M NOT I'M IN FAVOR
OF THE NONPROFIT METHOD OF
REGULATING. THIS PARTICULAR
OCCUPATION IF WE CAN MAKE IT
WORK BUT I DO THINK THIS
PARTICULAR ASPECT OF THE NEEDS
OF TIME AND ATTENTION. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
EXPLANATION I LOOK FORWARD
HAVING FURTHER CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATE ROTH. A QUESTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. YES
THANK YOU AND MOST OF MY
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED BUT
I- I DID HAVE A QUESTION OF I
WAS ON THE- CITY COUNCIL IN
THOUSAND OAKS AND THERE WAS A
HUGE CONCERN WITH THE
PROLIFERATION OF. I GUESS I'M
NOT SURE THE MASSAGE
INSTITUTIONS I GUESS- MAYBE
THAT IS THE- APPROPRIATE WORD.
BUT THEY DON'T THINK THAT THEY
CAN LIMIT THE NUMBER OF-
MASSAGE PARLORS IN THE IN THE-
CITY. IS THAT IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT CAN BE DONE ABOUT THAT AT
THE STATE LEVEL. I WILL ADDRESS
THAT- THE HAVE COMPLETE
CONTROL. OVER ANY LAND USE
ISSUES AND THE NUMBER OFF AT
ANY ESTABLISHMENT DATE THEY CAN
HAVE IN THE JURISDICTION- DODD
WAS A- IT WAS NOT CLEAR-
INDONESIA LAW THE GOVERNING LAW
FOR C. M. D. C. AND AFTER THE
FIRST SUNSET REVIEW CMT C.
SUPPORTED CHANGES IN THE
LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. CAN
COMPLETELY CONTROL THAT ASPECT
SO THERE THEY ARE FREE TO APPLY
ANY KIND OF LIMITS. I'D I'D I'D
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THEIR
UNDERSTANDING BUT I WILL
CERTAINLY- REPORT THAT BACK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT CENTER JULY THANK YOU MR-
THE SENATOR ROTH COACH ERIC
MENTIONED ABOUT- WORKING WITH
POLICE DEPARTMENT YOU SAID YOU
HAD MENTIONED THAT YOU WERE
CANDID HAVE POLICE CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS DEPARTMENT SHOW ON AND
YOU ENHANCE THEIR INVESTIGATION
SOMEWHERE THAT'S IMPRESSION
I'VE GOTTEN WITH ADVICE AND
COUNSEL WHAT ADVICE AND COUNSEL
DO YOU GIVE TH POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS. TO I GUESS ENHANCE
THE SAFETY AND PROTOCOL THE LAW
WHICH IS- PREVENTING ANY
ILLICIT ACTIVITY IN THESE-
MASSAGE PARLORS THAT TAKE PLACE
AND IN THE COURSE- WE'RE ALL
CONCERNED THAT THE THERAPIST
WHO TRULY TRULY WORKS WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL WE'VE BEEN IN AN
ACCIDENT AND SO ON- THAT THAT
IS VITAL THAT PHYSICAL
THERAPIST BUT THE OTHERS WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT BUT WHAT WHAT
GIVE THE DEPARTMENTS. THAT WILL
PREVENT THE OTHER PART OF THIS
WHOLE ISSUE. SO FIRST OF ALL-
PREVENTING IT COMPLETELY- I
DON'T KNOW TO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT CAN BE ACHIEVED ANYTIME
SOON UNFORTUNATELY. IT'S A
REALITY THAT WE ARE FACING ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY IN OTHER
STATES FORTY THREE OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE LICENSING LAWS AND
GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS AND
SONG- ARE A DIRECTOR ALL FELL
LAW ENFORCEMENT- RELATIONS. IS
THIRTY YEARS FORTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE IN- VICE AND MASSAGE
AT THE SHOES WITH LAPD. AND
HE'S THE ONE IN CHARGE CORD
PROVIDING THESE VERY RIGOROUS
TRAINING THAT WE PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATES ARE PROBABLY DISCUSS THE
TRAINING THAT WOULD PROVIDE IT
WOULD PROVIDE FREE OF CHARGE-
TOOL- LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT'S
THAT PROBABLY THE CORNERSTONE
OF WHAT WE DO. IN ADDITION TO
THAT THERE IS AN ONGOING VERY
ROBUST COMMUNICATION SHARING
BETWEEN SEEING P. C. AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO I'M JUST
THINKING ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
CASE- THAT- I REMEMBER FROM
LAST YEAR IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WHERE- SAN JOSE POLICE
DEPARTMENT ARRESTED A AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT ENGAGE IN-
CHILD **** A AND- WE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE DA- THE
MOMENT THE PA FILE CHARGES
FORTY FIVE MINUTES AFTER THE
CHARGES WERE FILED THIS
INDIVIDUAL WAS SUSPENDED- SO
THIS IS THE KIND OF SWIFT
ACTION WE HAVE WELL WE ARE
WORKING IN COORDINATION OF
COOPERATION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON A DAILY BASIS.
HE'S JUST IN ONE EXAMPLE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ACTUALLY. EDITION
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WILL GOING TO
EXPERT WITNESS TESTIMONY I KNOW
THE OPERATOR HAS THAT PERSON
ONLINE FOLLOWED BY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE CHAMBERS AND
THEN WILL GO TO OTHER
ADDITIONAL CALLERS. WHO ARE
ALSO ON THE LINE SO IF THE
OPERATOR CAN TURN TODAY- EXPERT
WITNESS- I UNDERSTAND THAT AT
SANTA CLARA COUNTY ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN IF
WE COULD HAVE YOUR COMMENTS TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES AND
THEN WE'LL GET TO. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE CHAMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CHAIRMAN LOW AND
SHERMAN ROTH AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME'S JEFF ROSEN
I'M THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. ALMOST ONE
YEAR AGO- ON MARCH THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY I SENT A LETTER
TO THIS COMMITTEE IN WHICH I
WROTE. THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL COMMITMENT TO
THE ERADICATION. OF ILLICIT
MASSAGE. IS INSTRUMENTAL IN OUR
FIGHT THE HUMAN- MY MISSION THE
DISH ATTORNEY IN SENECA COUNTY
IS TO. PUBLIC THROUGH THE
PREVENTION AND PROP. OF CRIME.
UP TO THE LEGISLATURE THIS AND
TRY. OH EIGHT TO. CMT C. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING LAW. A SCOURGE
LOCAL. PARTICULARLY MY CAL. OF
THERE'S A LOT OF. ABOUT THE
TRAUMA AND HORRIBLE THINGS THAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS DO- THE
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE SOMETHING
MEANINGFUL NEEDED TO BE DONE.
AND YOU CREATED AN INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATION. CMCC WHICH MUSCLE
AND DEXTERITY. CNPC IN MY
EXPERIENCE HAS THE- IN THE- AND
IT'S BEEN A AN EXTRA. PARTNER
IN OUR AFTER TO A BALL. HE
TRAFFICKING. I FEEL SO STRONG.
ABOUT THIS IS. THAT MY CAL AND
INTO AN MOU WITH C. C. THEY ARE
A PART. IN AND IN THIS. OF
TRAFFICKING INCLUDE AMONG THEIR
MANY RESPONSIBILITIES ARE.
NUMBER ONE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
ADMINISTER LOCAL ORDINANCES.
SHARING INFORMATION WITH THE DA
WHEN AUTHORIZED BY STATUTE
WRITTEN BY THIS COMMITTEE THAT
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY HELPFUL IN
OUR INVESTIGATION. AND.
PROSECUTIONS HERE. PROVIDING
SAID. ACTIONS PROVIDING STATUS
OF MISS THERE ARE SORT OF BY
TWO. C. SHE EDUCATIONAL
HIGHLIGHTING RAY AND A
SOLUTIONS AND COURSE PROVIDING
A- POINT OF. THE PARTNERSHIP
CMT C. SICK AND DEPTH IT IS
ALSO. THAT IS RE. IN FINDING
ANSWERS TO WHAT IT BEEN A FAST
PROBLEM. I A HUMAN TRAFFIC UNIT
THE DA'S OFFICE. OF TWO
PROSECUTORS AND SEVERAL DA
INVESTIGATORS WHO HAVE
COLLABORATED WITH CMP STAFF TO
CONDUCT MEANINGFUL OUT REACHING
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. I IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS CNBC IS
CONDUCTED MANY TRAININGS FOR
LOCAL POLICE ON IDENTIFYING
ILLICIT MASSAGE ESTABLISHMENTS
A MAJOR SOURCE FOR COMMERCIAL
SEX EXPLOITATION IN OUR REGION.
ALSO MY TEAM AT CMCC OF
INITIATED PILOT PROGRAMS OF
CRIMINAL AND REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT IN CITIES WITHIN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY INCLUDING
CAMPBELL. BEVERLY MACY MPC'S
DIRECTOR OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ASSISTED THE CAMPUS CITY
COUNCIL IN RETRACTING LOCAL
ORDINANCES FOR MASSAGE
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE
INSPECTORS AND POLICE THE TOOLS
FOR BETTER OVERSIGHT. SINCE
THIS WORK SEVERAL BAD ACTORS
WERE IDENTIFIED CNPC IN
CAMPBELL POLICE WORK. TOGETHER
TO SHUT DOWN SEVERAL. THE STOCK
BUSINESSES BY REVOKE MASSAGE
TIPPING AND PER. A THIRD IS
STILL UNDER INVESTIGATION. I
WILL CLOSE BY SAYING TODAY WHAT
I A PINE LAST YEAR. OR SEEN
LICENSURE WITHOUT A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPLICATIONS WILL PROFOUNDLY
AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR LONG
STANDING FIGHT AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AS THE DA OF THIS
COUNTY I AM ONLY INTERESTED IN
WHAT WORKS CNPC WORKS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
CHAIRMAN LOW AND CHAIRMAN ROCK
I APPRECIATE IT.THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SECOND TOURNEY ROSE IN-
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND
LEADERSHIP. AT SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BUT ALSO STATEWIDE IT
SPEAKS VOLUMES TO HAVE YOU WITH
US HERE TODAY WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE CHAMBERS
AS A REMINDER WE LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO TESTIFY
PLEASE FEEL FREE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THE MORNING
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME'S RON LAWRENCE AND THE
CHIEF OF POLICE FOR THE CITY OF
CITRUS HEIGHTS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. I'M ALSO THE IMMEDIATE
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TODAY.
REPRESENTING ALL THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO POLICE CHIEFS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHO
SENT ME HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL OR CMT C. THE
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
EXPRESSES OUR SINCERE
APPRECIATION AND SUPPORT OF C.
A. T. C. AND AS THE PRESIDENT
LAST YEAR I SENT YOU A LETTER
TO THIS COMMITTEE. ON SUPPORT
OF THEM AS YOU PROBABLY ALSO
RECEIVED A LETTER THIS YEAR
FROM OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT. AS
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION CFTC
IS DONE AMAZING WORK ASSISTING
CALIFORNIA POLICE
PROFESSIONALS. IN OUR EFFORTS
TO BRING AN END THE HORRIFIC
REALITIES OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IN CALIFORNIA. LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT COUNTY AND STATE
OFFICIALS WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS. TO ADDRESS
THE ENFORCEMENT OF THIS AS WELL
AS HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND YOU
MIGHT EVEN BE AWARE. IN EARLY
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR THERE WAS
A STATEWIDE CRACKDOWN ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RESULTING IN
FORDERN FIFTY ARRESTS.
INCLUDING DOZENS OF PEOPLE
RESCUED. CMT C. HAS BEEN A
CRUCIAL STRATEGIC PARTNER THE
POLICE CHIEF FOR MANY YEARS.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO ASSIST US
WITH THEIR STRUCTURAL SUPPORT
BY OFFERING VOLUNTARY
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS FOR
MASSAGE THERAPISTS. AND
PROFESSIONAL APPROVAL MASSAGE
THERAPY SCHOOLS IN OUR STATE
PREVENTING MUCH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE SUCCESSFUL CMT C. MODEL FOR
MASSAGE THERAPY CERTIFICATION
IN THERAPY SCHOOL APPROVAL. HAS
GREATLY HELPED US IDENTIFY AND
ROOT OUT ILLICIT ACTIVITY
ALLOWING FOR SWIFT ACTION TO BE
TAKEN ON ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES.
SUCH AS HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
PROSTITUTION. THE EXPEDIENCY
WITH WHICH CMT C. CAN
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
IMPROPRIETIES IN THE MASSAGE
THERAPY PROFESSION. FAR EXCEEDS
WHAT MORE CUMBERSOME LICENSING
BOARD OR LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
ACCOMPLISH ALONE. AS PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
COMMITMENT TO SHUT DOWN IRAQI
THAT IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
OUR STATE OR BOARD OF DIRECTORS
VOTED TO FULLY SUPPORT CFTC'S
CONTINUING TO THE NONPROFIT BY
THIS COMMITTEE. WE HOPE YOU'LL
JOIN US IN SUPPORT OF CMT C.
AND OUR CONTINUED FOCUS ON
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU JEFF
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
MIKE. WHENEVER READY AND THAT'S
TO GET TO THE MIKE THIS IS A
REMINDER TO MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE WE DO NEED. TO LEAVE
THIS THESE CHAMBERS AT TWELVE
NOON SO WILL PROVIDE. AS MUCH
EXPEDITIOUS TESTIMONIES
POSSIBLE PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU- GERMAN LOW
CHAIRMAN ROSS MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TONY PSYCHOSIS I'VE
BEEN A PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE
THERAPIST FOR THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS. WHEN FOR THE FIRST TWO.
SORRY CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW.
SORRY MY NAME IS TONY PSYCHOSIS
I'VE BEEN A PROFESSIONAL
MASSAGE THERAPIST FOR THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS FOR THE FIRST TWO
IN THE LAST EIGHT OF THOSE
YEARS I'VE PRACTICE MY
PROFESSION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND AS THEY LIKE TO
SAY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT. YOU
LOT DRIVE ME CRAZY. I HAVE LOST
COUNT OF THE NUMBER OF PUBLIC
HEARINGS I'VE ATTENDED WHERE I
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO TASK FOR NOT
STOPPING HUMAN TRAFFICKING DONE
UNDER THE GUISE OF MASSAGE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DECIDE WHO
OPERATE STOREFRONT MASSAGE
BUSINESSES IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN CITIES DEMANDED THIS
CONTROL AND GOT IT WITH AB ONE.
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN WHAT IS
ALWAYS ALWAYS MISSED IN THIS
CONVERSATION IS THAT THESE
BUSINESSES ARE IMPOSTERS THEY
ARE PRETENDERS THAT GAME THE
SYSTEM TO OPEN A STOREFRONT
MASSAGE BUSINESS WITH THE
INTENT OF OPERATING A
COMMERCIAL SEX BUSINESS. THIS
IS A SYSTEM OVER WHICH NEITHER
CA MTC OR THE PROFESSIONAL
MASSAGE THERAPISTS HAVE ANY
CONTROL YET FOR WHICH WE ARE
REPEATEDLY REPEATEDLY BLAMED WE
WANT WHAT YOU WANT STOP
PRETENDING THAT WE DON'T AND
START UTILIZING OUR EXPERTISE
TO ACTUALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK. C. NINE WILL
GO TEND TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE CALL OPERATOR
WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN UP AND
JUST AS A REMINDER IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLICLY IS
REPEATING A POSITION THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN STATED PREVIOUSLY.
PLEASE ONLY INDICATE YOUR NAME
AND POSITION AS WE MUST THE
JOURNALIST AND TWELVE NOON
TODAY. OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL OR C. MTT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOUR
LINE NUMBERS WHEN YOU'RE MY
NUMBER'S CALLED PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU DO HAVE A COMMENT.
ON THE C. M. T. C. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT FIVE FIRST
COMMENT. NINE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES OKAY AND HI AN CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS JEAN JELLO. I AM-
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF CHINESE MEDICINE
AND ACUPUNCTURE ACMA- WE HAVE A
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS. BUT TODAY
WE I WANT TO HAVE HIGHLY
SUGGESTION IS. POSTED THERE
THERE IS THERE ARE SO TEAM
MEMBERS IN THE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL. NONE OF THEM ARE ASIAN
OR CHINESE. IN MY SAID INDUSTRY
ABOUT 25% OF CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST I ASIAN. THERE SHOULD
BE AT LEAST A TWO ASIAN OR
CHINESE THE REPRESENTATIVE IN
THE BOARD OF THE C. M. P. C.
MERCED SYRUPY IS ALSO INCLUDED.
IN THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR
CALIFORNIA LICENSE ACTIVE WITH.
I'M SUGGEST THAT ONE BOARD
MEMBER SHOULD BE RECOMMENDED BY
DEATH CALIFORNIA OCCUPIED AFTER
PUNCH ABOUT. UNIDO I WANT TO
SAY S. ACUPUNCTURE SCHOOL HAD
BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH OF A
CALIFORNIA OCCUPYING TROUBLED
AND AC A. O. N. M. PROGRAM OF
BY. SCHOOLS MADE THE STANDARD
OF THE MASSAGE. COOL BUT AND-
BURKE COUNTY X. DON'T CITED
SAID BY BOTH AGING. THEY A
HIGHER. FOR MASSAGE PROGRAM
FROM THE ASIAN CHINESE
COMMENDED. WITH THE STRONGLY
SUGGESTED THAT C. M. T. C.
QUICKLY APPROVED PROCESS OF MY
SUCH PROGRAM OFFERED BY DAYS
OCCUPIED YOUR SCHOOL TO MEET
THIS DEMAND THANK YOU YOUR TWO
MINUTES ISN'T NEXT CALLER. NINE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TO DECLARE
I'M A MASSAGE THERAPIST AND
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I THINK IN
SUPPORT OF C. MPP CONTINUING AS
THE MODEL FOR EIGHT MINUTES
STIRRING THE MASSAGE THERAPY
ACT. IT'LL ONLY RESPONSIBLE
THING TO DO. AND PETER NOT USE.
PAYER DOLLARS OPERATE AN AD
STATES BUDGETARY BURDEN OF
PENSIONS. PMPC PROVIDE CRITICAL
SUPPORT THE CITY AND COUNTIES
AND LOCKPORT TO RECOGNIZE
THERAPEUTIC MASSAGE AND REMOVE
COMMERCIAL. ACTORS HE IS
CHRISTIAN BECAUSE IS CALLED ON.
BECOME OF MY- WHICH IS BLOCKED
IN WITH COMMERCIAL BACK AS IT'S
BEEN NOTED BY THE TODAY. I URGE.
YOU TO KEEP YAKKING TO SEE
DOING WHAT IT WHAT THE SIGN TO.
AND DOES EFFECTIVELY. SAVE
MONEY. AT THE NON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION. DISTINGUISH
MASSAGE THERAPIST IS HEALING
PROFESSIONAL AND NOT.
COMMERCIAL SEX OPERATIVE. AND
THIRDLY ESTABLISH AND
ADMINISTER MASSAGE SCHOOL
APPROVAL PROGRAMS FOR GRADUATES
SAFELY TOUCH THE PUBLIC. WE TRY
AND CREATE ON. ERIC. ONE PARTY
AT A TOPIC. AND OVER THE YEARS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC.
IT'S GOING TO BE AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN AND EVERY TIME THERE'S
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. MEURSAULT
FACT PROSTITUTION AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. HIM TO BE ON AN
UPTICK BUT IT ISN'T THE BURDEN
OF. ERIC YOU TAKE MY FIVE
PROVIDERS TO FIX THAT PROBLEM.
THE WAY THAT THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION MET UP THEY REGULATE
ESTHETICIAN ESTABLISHMENTS
STARTED NOT CA IN TWO THREE
JOBS MAYBE THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO CREATE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATION THAT CAN
WORK IN. CORRELATION WITH WHAT
CNPC HAS DONE AND ADDS TO THE-
DISTRICT ATTORNEY RESIDENT
STATED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS LUANNE HIGH POWER AND
HIGH TECH PROBLEMS GETTING BMTC
MEMBERSHIP BECAUSE I DID NOT
ATTEND A SCHOOL THAT WAS
RECOGNIZED BY THE CA NINETY
THREE. I GAINED MY NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION THROUGH THE M. C.
B. T. M. B. THE NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION BODY IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE I SUBMITTED OVER A
THOUSAND HOURS OF EDUCATION.
PASSED THE WRITTEN EXAM.
ADMITTED FIVE HUNDRED CLIENT
CONTENT DESPERATE. NUMBER TWO
GAME APP STATUS. I ON THE RENEW
TOO BAD TO THE DAY I SAT- IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN FURTHERMORE
PRESS BOARD CERTIFICATION- EXAM
AND PASSED. AND YET THE PAM
CHIEF HE WILL NOT LET ME INTO
THEIR RANKS BECAUSE I DIDN'T GO
TO ONE OF TO SCHOOL WHEN I
STUDIED MASSAGE THERE WERE NOT
A LOT OF TIMES. IT'LL STOP
THIRTY PERSONALLY WITH
LUMINARIES IN THE FIELD LIKE
LEON CHIDES HAVE EITHER CARACAS
JOHN BARNES BARBARA BRENNAN
EVEN BEFORE THEY ESTABLISH
THEIR SCHOOLS OF HEALING. AND
ARBOR IS- AT. CREDIT LUCKILY
THE CITY OF FROM GRANT ME A
BILL LINE. BASED ON PRESENT OF
MY CREDENTIALS AND A LETTER
FROM THE NCTM. BUT I'M AFRAID
THAT I CAN'T MOVE OUT OF
SACRAMENTO AND BE ABLE TO
LEGALLY PRACTICE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE NOBODY
WILL RECOGNIZE MY NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION- THE CMT IS HOW
DOES THE FOLLOWING- AND-
VOLUNTARY MEMBERSHIP. BUT IT'S
CLEARLY NOT VOLUNTARY WHEN YOU
CAN'T TEACH AT A MASSAGE SCHOOL
WITHOUT BEING A MEMBER OF THE
C. MCC. AND MANY COUNTIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES WON'T GRANT YOU
A BUSINESS LICENSE WITHOUT ALSO
BEING A MEMBER OF THE C. A. M.
P. THREE I THINK THAT THE VERY
NEGLIGENT IT'S- BASE. IT'S
THAT'S VERGING ON AGEISM I'M
SIXTY ONE YEARS OLD AND MY
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE COUNTS FOR NOTHING
WITH THEM. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. SOMETHING DONE ABOUT THAT.
TO TAKE AWAY THAT OUR MONEY ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY YEAH- AND
LIMóN AND PRACTICING RESPONSE
FOR TWENTY YEARS. MOST OF MY
PRACTICE HAS BEEN IN OREGON SO
COMING FROM A STATE ACTUALLY
HOUSE GLEISON STATUS. WHAT THE
BOND CERTIFICATE. IS AREA. VERY
DIFFICULT- OTHER EMPLOYERS I
CAN TELL YOU ABOUT IT. ALL PMPC.
THE VOLUNTARY THE COUNTY IS
UNDER THIRTY AND MAKING CHOICES
THAT DIFFER FROM ONE ANOTHER
LIAM EMPLOYERS WITH A SMALLER
BANK OF MASSAGE THERAPISTS THE
TRUTH. SO WITH THAT BEING SAID-
I WOULD REALLY HIGHLY LYFT
COULD PC MPP DEAR. I THANK OUR
COUNTRY YEAR BREAK. EIGHT
PROGRAM AS THEIR K. A FEW
THINGS I WANTED TO BRING. AS
PART OF THEIR OUR WAGE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED- EARLIER. COULD YOU
RUN ON A FIFTY TO TWENTY
DOLLARS PER HOUR PLUS. ONE
THIRTY. OUR SERVICE IS DONE. I
WANT KNOW OKAY THREE IF YOU'RE
JOB TO GET THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND- NOT THEIR MAIN FOCUS. HOW
IS DURING PANDEMIC IN THE AS
WELL AS KEEPING THE PUBLIC
STAGE. BECAUSE EVERYBODY HAS
CONTINUING TO WORK AND IF
YOU'RE TRUE A CONCERNED ABOUT
SPECTRUM AND LEARN HOW YOU IN
OUR IN OPEN. AND THE OUTLAW IN.
OF SAFETY. I BY TO KNOW ABOUT
IT AT ALL LIKE TO KNOW WHY AN
TO SEE THE NOT A TO SCOPE OF
PRACTICE BECAUSE KIND. STATE OF.
HAS A- DEFINED. SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR FIVE THIRTY. DOES
NOT. AND THEN FOR THE STATE
SENATOR. I DON'T MEMBER I
WANTED WHY ARE YOU GUYS NOT
INTERESTED AND A CITY LICENSING
BERMAN THERE. ALL THE THINGS
HAVE LAYS BEEN BEEN- OPEN SINCE
JUNE WORK AND I PLAN. LAST NOT
BE A TO FOR YOU AND COUNTY. AND
NOT FRANKLY AS DISCUSSING TWO
YEARS KNOWING THAT IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH C. M. FIFTY THANK YOU
FOR AND- EARNED. THREE MY ONE
SIX NINE LINE IS A PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CREAKING EVERYONE MY
SEEN YOUNG I WANT TO OUR WHY
CMC. OPPOSITION INCRETIN T. I'M
NOT. TWENTY SEVENTEEN NOT I'M I
AM COME PAPERWORK FIVE OUR AT
FIVE THANK YOU YOU LOOK AT BUT
ALSO POTS THE FINAL TASK. I
THOUGHT THAT I WOULD. RECEIVE
THE ACTIVITY CASE I REACH THOSE.
ALL THE AN SEATS YEAH. PRICE I
TOO COOL PROVIDER MIGHT BE REAL
BACK AND PULLED HE BY THE FIVE
LITER YOU LOOK P. WE ALREADY
OF. EMAIL FROM YOU SEE BY THANK
ON THE NEW CALIFORNIA LAW.
FINALLY AND- HERE TO READ THE
WHOLE NOT LONG NAY COMPLETING
FINES UNDER ALL AND THE FIVE-
FIVE BRANCHES TO YOU P. SOME OF
THE AND AFFECTED BY WE WILL
EXPECT THE FACT THE RESULT OF
THIS. I'M NOT. THREE MONTHS
LATER ON AT. TWENTY NINETEEN SB
THREE. ANOTHER FONG AND HE'S IT
RIGHT I. THANK YOU AND THE
PEOPLE COPIES I'M NOT A PARTY.
MIKE THE CALL CAN NOT HE-
TECHNIQUE BY THE. FIVE HUNDRED
REQUIREMENTS THE REASON WHY I
TO ATTEND BY THANK YOU YOU LOOK
AT. TWENTY SEVENTEEN HE CALLED
IT NEEDS APPROVED SCHOOL FIGHT
THE M. G. THREE WHY THEY
PROBLEM THE CARD PLEASE COULD
NOT AFFECT STATE. TWENTY NINE.
FOR HIM THE DOCTOR TO COUNSEL
AND THE CONTINUATION OF THE
COUNCIL OF THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION IMPLEMENTING A
STATEWIDE VOLUNTARY
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
MASSAGE PROFESSIONALS AND
APPROVAL OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS THE COUNTY HAS
CONTINUED TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS
THAT HELP AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND WE SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
COUNCIL HAS DONE TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. WE AGREE
WITH OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS A NUMBER
OF ORGANIZATIONS TO FIGHT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ON A DAILY BASIS IN
SUPPORT OF THE COUNCIL. THANK
YOU. NINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS CHRISTINE HUBER WITH
THE AMERICAN PSYCHOTHERAPY
ASSOCIATION. IN HIS MISSION AT
THE ADVOCATE FOR FAIR AND
CONSISTENT PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING OF MASSAGE THERAPY
AND ALL FIFTY STATESAS WELL AS
US TERRITORIES. CALIFORNIA IS
ONLY ONE OF FIVE STATES WITHOUT
STATEWIDE LICENSURE. THE PUBLIC
HAS A RIGHT TO EXPECT THAT A
MASSAGE THERAPIST HAS THE
QUALIFICATIONS NEEDED TO
PRACTICE EFFECTIVELY AND
SAFELY. LEGAL RECOGNITION OF
THE PRACTICE OF MASSAGE THERAPY
AND CLEARLY FAIR LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS TO PRACTICE ARE
CENTRAL TO THE PROTECT THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
THE PUBLIC AND EVERY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURES TWO THOUSAND NINE
AUTHORIZING STATUTE HAS TO BE A
AT SEVEN THIRTY ONE WAS
INTENDED TO BE A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION MORE THAN TEN YEARS
LATER AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES JUST HOLD
A VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. WHICH HAS NOTHING TO
REGULATE THE ACTUAL PRACTICE OF
MASSAGE THERAPY MOST
SPECIFICALLY THERE'S NO LEGALLY
DEFINED SCOPE OF PRACTICE WHICH
IS A MAJOR COMPONENT OF PUBLIC
PROTECTION HODGEPODGE OF LOCAL
MUNICIPAL ORDINANCES ALL AGREED
TO GET FINE. BARRIERS FROM THE
THERE. OUR GROWTH IN KNOWING IS
TWENTY NINE TWO AND THEN PUT
NINE DOLLARS A YEAR. MANY
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE A DISH
FEES WHICH CAN BE MORE TWENTY
HUNDRED TO BE. ON OF THE TWO
AND DOLLARS OR- PERMINTAAN
THERAPISTS PRACTICE IN A LOT
ANGELES AREA IF YOU CAN ECONOMY
ONE OF THEIR- YOU TO THE MALL
CHOICE. I THE GUY PRESENCE
WITHIN BOTH. AND NASH HEALTH
CARE. BESIDES THERE RECORD
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS ACTIVE TREATMENT FOR
CHRONIC PAIN. AS A RESULT OF
SUCH THERAPIES INCLUDED INDIA
D. V. EIGHT PAIN MANAGEMENT
GUIDELINES. AND A COVERED
SERVICE INDIA DEVIATE THE
FELONIES. PDA HAS ESTABLISHED
JEEZ AT FIVE THREE GS NINE
POSITION FOR ALL STATE LIFE
LIGHT. SAUCE THERE. THE CENTERS
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
SERVICES HAVE DIRECT AN THE
PLANNED GUY. MASSAGE PROVIDE
PROVIDED BY STATE LICENSED
THERAPIST COULD BE A COUPLE
BENEFIT WITHIN MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE PLANS. SIMILARLY
MCCARTY- MUCH EMAILED OUT AND
THE FACT. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN LOW AND ROCK- MY NAME
IS STAN GARAGE I'VE BEEN A
SINGLE PAYER BECAUSE AS WELL AS
A CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST
IN CALIFORNIA. I LIVE IN THE LA
AREA AND HAVE BEEN PRACTICING
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. FOR
FORTY YEARS I HAVE- A CHAIN OF
THE SIZE CENTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
VISITED BY THE LA CITY OF
BUSINESS AS WELL AS THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT EVERY YEAR. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS NO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING EVER PROPERLY
APPLIED TO THE SPECIALLY BY THE
CNPC- COUNTY ON THE CMP- AND-
IN YOUR THERAPIST LEVEL
PROFESSION. AND JUST THE
STANDARD HAVE BEEN- PERFORMED-
FUNDING LEVELS OF THE PUBLIC
RESPECT AND- TRUCKS CONTINUING
TO RISE THE PUBLIC AND THE
THERAPIST ARE COUNTING ON THEM
TO KEEPING THE SAFETY AND THE
MORE ACCOUNTABLE. I DO RESPECT
THE- THE COUNCIL AND I THINK
THAT THE MAKING A CHANGE IN
THIS POINT WOULD MAKE A BIG
MISTAKE ESPECIALLY TO ALL THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS THE
PROFESSION FOR THOUSANDS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVE A GOOD DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES THE A TIME OF OUR
HEARING IT IS NOW TWELVE NOON
TO WHICH WE MUST. EXIT THE
CHAMBERS HERE FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO DID NOT. YEAH WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO HEAR YOUR
COMMENTS OF WILL HAVE FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND IF YOU'RE NEAR
FUTURE AS WE ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES. TO
ALMOST AND YOUR ENTIRE TEAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MAKING
YOURSELF READILY AVAILABLE. AT
WE LOOK FOR TO THE CONTINUED
DIALOGUE AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
INFORMATION HEARING WE ARE
JORDAN THANK YOU.